hello chairman thank you thank you Tara
Gooding you everybody and welcome to
this meeting of the Malden District
Council which is held on Thursday the
14th of September 2023.
my name is councilor Kevin Lagan I'm the
chairperson of the council members are
all present we're streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you're giving
your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I'll
then invite you at the appropriate time
that may not be necessarily in the order
of which your hand was raised it depends
when we pick them up
could I ask members to avoid approaching
the top bench here as it could interfere
with the cameras and live stream
mechanism and please note that YouTube
live stream sound recording is dependent
on the correct use of microphones
therefore can I ask that when invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
thank you a gender item two apologies
for absence Tara could we have apologies
for absence please
thank you thank you just to also note
that with just received apologies from
councilor stilts
thank you very much Kevin thank you very
much
move on to agenda item number three
which is the minutes of the 13th of July
2023 this is to confirm the minutes of
the the council meeting held on the 13th
of July 2023 found on pages 5 to 22 of
the agenda pack I move this
recommendation do I have a seconder
secondary thank you councilor siddle
councilor fluka thank you chairman uh
just just really some points of uh
accuracy and and also the fact that I
think that you know fully understand the
minutes are not a contemporaneous note
and they are only actually notes but I
think it's right and proper that when
comments are made uh and they uh rely on
the outcome of proposals then they
should be properly recorded in the
minutes and and chairman I'd draw your
attention to minute 156 in particular
and I would also say chairman the
monitoring officer also advised members
that for the motion to succeed the vote
had to be unanimous German it looks as
though you gave the council that legal
advice and not the monitoring officer
which was in fact the case and it's
quite clear to hear on the tape and
Kevin following on from that and this is
a point of accuracy a recorded vote was
agreed
and it was it was agreed that the vote
should be recorded and although the vote
should have been taken and recorded in
its entirety the chair decided to stop
the vote at the point the Council of
driver voted against the motion up to
that point at the very very least the
votes for members should have been
recorded and thereafter shown in the
minutes as to do otherwise it'd be
incorrect we didn't we actually we
actually
the vote started you you agreed to stop
here whether or not that was correct in
my mind I think it should have gone
through even though we've been told that
if one vote uh was against the proposal
the motion would fail but you would
still have to do that so chairman I hope
you consider putting that into the
minutes
um
chairman as far as minute 157 is
concerned what I actually said was that
under the rules and less agreed by the
chairperson all motions should stand
defer to the appropriate committee
is to do otherwise it would be
anti-democratic but our laws actually
say that chairman and we seem to get in
a huge muddle by trying to deal with all
emotions in Council and this is what I
was trying to point out
um chairman minute 164.
uh again chairman I um sorry do do you
want to comment or and I'm quite happy
to take an answer afterwards chairman
I'll let you let you raise the points
and then yes yes okay so um minute one
six four
um
chairman
my preamble to my proposal chairman
should be included in the minutes I mean
if somebody makes a proposal there has
to be a preamble in there to support it
um you know I mentioned the impacts and
disruption to our residents from the
massive developments in modern haybridge
South Wilson and Bernard at the
residence have basically been eating
dust and dirt for a number of years and
that new homes bonus should be used to
offset that that disruption by providing
local infrastructure rather than popping
up the general fund which I mean that is
really important to have in the minutes
because that is what we were considering
at that time
um
so and then chairman
I know that you've had a conversation
with a mansion officer uh you know I've
spoken to you about this but as far as
I'm concerned chairman I made a proposal
and it was definitely seconded
and and chairman in your role you you
actually acknowledge that and I think if
members go to paragraph eight of the
minute
164. uh you actually say my motion was
seconded and therefore was including in
the ascent given by Council no members
chairman challenge your decision no but
nobody to challenge that and then
chairman a police meet a post a
post-mating note
uh in the minutes and I mean perhaps you
can let me know who the authors of that
post minute note
um the author is actually silent
reverses your decision chairman and I've
I've I've never ever seen that in a
council meeting where a decision is made
and then it subsequently reversed so for
clarity chairman and to support your
initial decision because in all fairness
you've actually empowered Our Fate
you've actually said that it was it was
seconded and it was agreed by a cent uh
so to support your initial decision you
might like to ask
uh who seconded my motion and thereafter
agree that the minutes are greeted
agreed accordingly thank you oh amended
accordingly thank you thank you
councilor there's an awful lot and um I
appreciate your diligence are going
through the minutes
um from the perspective
of the second in the minute I don't
believe that that was actually seconded
so well that might be an error in the
meeting I'll check that and then we'll
get that refreshed I I mean if if I've
asked you to ask Council if it was
seconded I've listened to the tape
several times and you can hear somebody
second it and I think gem for clarity
because I think the monitoring officer
bases his case on the fact that no one
seconded it even though you thought it
was and that you brought my motion
forward as part of the overall thing I
mean I know how people how passionate
people are I know how passionate well
Duke has the flu kid thank you because
we are talking about the meetings we're
not talking about how passionate people
are what we'll do is under rule 22 I'll
take that away and I'll look at that and
then if it is the case then I'll bring
that back to council uh the next
chairman with the greatest respect time
is not on our side and I would ask you
to consider again putting the question
to council so that you can establish who
seconded it otherwise it's six weeks
wasted thank you chairman thank you
councilor stamp
Casa Neo
thank you chair um just to say I think
it was actually myself for the second in
that motion um because I believe I was
behind
other councils and you I couldn't be
seen I haven't double checked the tape
but I'm presuming it was myself thank
you thank you Council
we proceed
um I need to get the clarity on that and
I think
yeah
so I feel I still want to tell me I
don't think there's any
I don't think there's any it's in a
difficult situation Council fluke
because I need to go back and check
um and I think to for accuracy that that
needs to be done and then as I said I'm
prepared to come back to council and ask
the question
um once I've got Clarity unless any
other members on can remember that being
the case councilavin
uh yeah actually I actually was sitting
in front and it was councilor Neil the
second did it because I was actually
sitting in front of him I heard him say
it okay time well from that situation
[Music]
we probably need to do
I just seeking some advice just bear
with me a second because rather a
complex situation yeah
what are you actually seeking counselor
fluco it can be in the clarity of the
last point on the minutes please I'm I'm
sorry German I didn't quite catch that
so uh what exactly uh R do you want to
clarification what what a part of this
mean minutes do you want to mentioned
for clarity I want the minutes to
include the point that councilor Neil
um supported my seconded my proposal
which is what happened I mean you've
clearly got counselor Hayward and you've
now got in councilor Neil who were both
sitting down in front of me and and for
you to say chairman that it had you know
it paragraph eight chairman you know
you've had sight of these meetings
minutes long before me and you agreed to
put that what's in paragraph eight and
just to remind members it said my motion
was seconded and therefore was included
in new Saint given by Council those
aren't my words German they're yours and
I think we all stand by those thank you
here with us a second
that's what he said he wants to make
sure this has gone for this procedurally
correct because you'll understand I want
to be as accurate as well your good self
is
there's something squeaking
I've had cancer fluke I've I've believed
that in the meeting that I corrected
that and I may have been mistaken and it
said that the meeting wasn't the motion
wasn't second and I remember doing that
which may be an error on my behalf I
need to check that so I'm going to defer
that and come back at the next council
meeting
chairman of this Castle
thank you Chad the the key I think one
of the key issues on this is normally
when something is seconded and minuted
it has the name of the person and that
name is recorded and I don't remember
any name being mentioned when that was
seconded and that's why in these minutes
there are there is no bar Name by the
seconder so therefore that that was not
seconded
but there was no name at that time that
said seconded by
councilor Neil
um thank you thank you
what's in the minutes but this is this
is the whole purpose of this agenda item
is to confirm the minutes and clearly
this has been missed off these minutes
cancel the fluke this is to to agree to
that exactly but what we need to do we
need to go back and I need to check with
Clarity and then I need to come back to
council with a definitive am I right or
am I wrong and that's that's where I
rule we're at at the moment thank you
counselor Morgan
uh thank you Mr chairman I wish to
comment on paragraph one five four of
the minutes which can be found on page
nine
now this deals with my reply to a
question from councilor stamp regarding
a remark that I made in a meeting
or previous meeting that meeting was in
fact confidential so I should not have
made any response to her query however I
did and for that breach of
confidentiality I apologize to the
council
I've also subsequently become aware that
my reply could be regarded as a direct
impunment of the veracity and integrity
of a member of this Council that was not
my intention and accordingly I apologize
to the said member for any hurtful
distress that they may have subsequently
suffered as a result of Mario party
thank you I'll allow that to go through
um because of its content members
anybody else got any other comments on
the meetings counselor White please
chairman
chairman um thank councilman Morgan for
his statement that he just made um
because comments were made that weren't
true and I do appreciate the
clarification so thank you very much
thank you very much indeed Council the
white
okay members with with those Amendments
of those areas that we need to check do
members agree that the minutes with
those points noted um can be passed by
us in great agreed thank you members
okay we need to move on to number four
which is Declarations of Interest this
is to disclose the existence and nature
of any disclosable pecuniary interests
other registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members members
are reminded that they are also required
to disclose any such interest as soon as
they come aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting members do have
any declarations please
no declarations Katara thank you so we
move on to agenda item five which is
public questions I can advise and there
was a paper issue to all members earlier
I advise that we did have a a written
question from a member of the public
which has been responded to in writing
number six my announcements chairperson
announcements I I just have a couple of
points one is um just to remind Council
the Council of Boyce is still uh unwell
I'm sure we wish his continued recovery
and so let's keep him in our our
thoughts
um the second one is also is a statement
from myself although chairman of the
council I'm also an elected member that
gives me the right to comment and vote
where I feel free and I will continue to
do that on the agenda issues in front of
me and the issues that benefit the award
of South Malden and the Malden District
so it's not political it's about voting
for the right things in the right way
just wanted to be really clear on that
thank you we move to a gender item seven
which is the minute book
there's no recommendations coming
forward from committees
a gender item eight members is minutes
of meetings of the council this is to
note that since the last Council up
until Wednesday the 6th of September
2023 Council agenda dispatch the
following committees have met and to
receive any questions in accordance with
Council and committee procedure rule six
level two it was Central area planning
committee on the 5th of July 2023
District planning committee on the 11th
of July 2023 strategy and resources
committee 20th of July
Southeast player area planning committee
26th of July performance governance and
audit committee 27th of July overview
and scrutiny committee first of August
Northwest area planning committee 16th
of August and Central area planning
committee 30th of August I propose these
minutes are agreed by Ascent members
Reed thank you very much indeed
move to agenda item 9 which is questions
in accordance with procedural 6 3 of
which notice have been given I've been
advised there are none
we move on to agenda item 10 which is
Constitution of the joint standards
committee this is found on pages 23 to
26 of the agenda pack
um Tara I understand that we should have
two the non-voting members joining the
meeting remotely and this has been
confirmed as their non-voting members
that's acceptable by the monitoring
offers can you confirm that they're in
attendance please
[Music]
committee not the sexual report item yep
just uh
thank you very much Tara okay okay so
the report is found on pages 23 to 26 of
your agenda pack and the officer
presenting is Miss Holmes thank you
good evening members
uh in accordance with the terms of
reference
of the council uh the council is
required to have a joint standards
committee to deal with any issues that
come up at the council meeting on the
13th of July this year the council
disbanded The Joint standards committee
without establishing a new composition
there was a no new composition even
though it wasn't agreed the motion to
just disapply political Provisions
failed the Constitution requires the
council as does section 53 of the local
government enact to have a standard
committee although there are no detailed
Provisions in relation
to its composition
as such the council is required to have
a joint Standards Commission committee
and to appoint members onto that in line
with the political balance legislation
the recommendations
the recommendations following that the
report is that in accordance with the
terms of reference for JSC eight members
are appointed to the committee along
with the two previously appointed Parish
councilors who are non-voting and the
independent person who's non-voting in
accordance with political balance rules
rules and secondly that the vice
chairman is not from the same political
group as the chairperson
thank you very much indeed
um so there's the recommendation so
we'll have a second for those
recommendations thank you thank you
councilor settle members councilor stamp
thank you chairman
um I'd just like to say actually how
disappointed I am that we're actually
going to go back to the old ways of
working where the the
um
the leading party has more members the
reason I brought that Council that
motion to council was so it's going to
be fair to everybody so this committee
would be equally balanced
um
maybe some members didn't quite
understand what we were trying to
achieve that's fair enough but really to
Chairman to have that motion voted down
and now we're going to go back to have
the I'm going to say the conservative
group have more members than the rest of
us there was a reason why that was
changing councilor Matt Bassinger will
well he maybe won't agree with me
nowadays but he understood exactly why
that motion was put at the time because
councilor siddler and I put that motion
and I see this is a backward Renegade
step going back to that and I understand
the reasons for doing it but I just like
that minuted noting please uh Clark that
I'm very disappointed we're going back
so we were trying to move forward thank
you thank you councilor stem any other
members wish to speak before we call for
nominations
foreign
members got any nominations councilor
settle please uh yes so uh to nominate
form one of the three groups uh the
district support group liberal Democrat
group and the Malden District
independent group I would like to from
the modern District independent group
nominate uh councilor Stevens
there's a second to please seconded and
councilor passenger any other
nominations please
okay it's Stevens
yes I'd like to nominate for the
position of chair
um
so members so I'll take these
individually um could I um calcium has
been nominated for that position
because we need to do one another
Library okay so I'll do this with the
three groups cancel the stamp
chairman I'd like to nominate councilor
Haywood is that secondary please
thank you
executive by Council Neil yeah sorry I
got it I've got to live there councilman
Morgan
uh thank you Jim I'd like to nominate
from our group uh councilor leiborne
councilor Thompson and councilor with an
hero yeah well that's what I thought
these are just these are just for the
spare pieces sorry yep that's fine I was
gonna respectfully stop you there
because you've already been appointed so
we've got um sorry counselor thank you
chair I'd like to uh nominate councilor
uh from the liberal Democrat group thank
you yeah seconded please okay thank you
executed by councilor Burwood any other
nominations members for this this is
from the the threes from the district
support liberal Democrat Malden
um District independent group
um we might as well take um the
non-aligned member and then we'll do the
voting afterwards so councilor siddle
please
uh yes I'd like to nominate councilor
lay
any other nominations from another line
do seconded thank you very much indeed
councilor Bassinger
nobody else on that one
okay I'm gonna take the easier one first
because we've had one underlying member
so can we agree that Council lay is
nominated by Ascent members please great
thank you very much indeed and now we
have uh councilor Stevens uh councilor
Heywood and councilor Jennings
um all nominations have been seconded so
um first of all I'm going to ask for
nominations for councilors Stevens
um could we do this by shower hands I
think was probably the only way I'm
going to be able to do this
do you agree well you've got three other
men you've got two other nominations so
you can't just agree that we've got to
go we've got to vote based on numbers
German I don't think we can just do it
on a show of hands of who we want on
um I would have thought that it's we've
got to have a proper ballad uh and then
one person's got to drop out and then
we're gonna have a shootout at the end
which is which is the normal way of
doing these things I mean we've got
involved in enough models doing this in
the past I'm sorry but that is the way
my friend over there who says I'm
correct yes rare
yeah
well what we'll have to do
um a bit advised um by the deputy
monitoring officer that we can we can
have a ballot here and we're going to
call names
uh first of all we're going to go four
against or abstain okay so I want to be
really clear cancel the fluke will
cancel the white please just opens this
is what make sure I get this right okay
that's uh it's really important
everything is done correctly
um so we're going to do a vote for
councilor Stevens first and uh names
Tara so it would be very similar to
recording vote in case it will capture
it that way so Tara this is the vote for
councilor Stevens please
each person individually
or each person individually
yeah please like very much like the way
I recorded but just be with the entire
sorry councilor Morgan yes sorry Mr
chairman I'm I'm sorry I'm getting
confused here I I was under the
impression that each of the three groups
the support group liberal Democrat and
more independently it was a lead was was
putting forward a further person and
therefore if they'd already nominated
we have we have just to be clear we've
got three from the conservative we've
got one already from District support
we've got one from Liberal Democrat one
from the more District independent
groups we have one on the line plus we
needed another non-aligned and we need
another representative from the three
groups
uh thank you chair I I seem to remember
in July when we uh voted for the uh
Parish Council representation what we
did was to go around everybody and they
said a name
um and whoever came out first was was
and then the other two
had a fight out in terms of the last
position as it is
yeah I think we just go for this I think
I think that uh
no I think I think what we need to do
councilor White
the easy way of doing it yeah yeah I
think I think that could be right but
obviously we're trying to go paperless
and um
I'm just going to take some advice again
because I've got how I would like to do
it but I just want to make sure it's
procedurally correct thank you
if we do each one person then do right
if you go to the next person so I'm
going to do Stephen's first and then
we'll do Haywood
everybody has a vote
if they all vote for everyone
okay
thank you very much
[Music]
yeah
so everybody's rights at home I record
that
okay so I've just taken some advice
excuse my ignorance but why can't we
just take all three
so now you can't because it's actually
set in the Constitution the numbers of
members that need to be in there can we
not change the Constitution no that's
important
[Music]
it's a very good point and it does make
a lot of sense but we have to deal with
it in the order that it's done so you're
dead right I mean we we had a last time
when we had the um the members from
outside from the parishes we did we did
we went around and people gave their
their nominated person so if members are
minded we could do that
um with the three nominations and again
whoever gets the most nominations
um
but basically takes it
I think that's it is I think that's the
easiest way
I don't know I think after the majority
on this today
yeah
yeah so we're going to go around and
we're gonna we're gonna call a name okay
you vote and we'll capture them uh Miss
Holmes you can do that and then the the
person with the lease vouch drops out
and then we go for the vote again for
that way is that clear Tara is that
procedurally correct and acceptable
thank you very much thank you very much
indeed so I need to go around the
chamber and ask for your nominated so
councilor Morgan please uh councilor
Stevens
thank you
councilor Stevens
Council Thompson
councilor Stevens thank you Council
Brown
Council Stevens
Council laven
counselor Haywood I would I apologize
Linda
Haywood thank you that's the Haywood
thank you thank you councilor stamp
Council fluka councilor Heywood thank
you councilor Norman councilor Haywood
thank you councilor lay councilor
Stevens thank you
counselor Paula spenceley councilor
Jennings
councilman
Lisa um counselor Jennings thank you
councilor Burwood councilor Jennings
thank you
indeed
Council Jennings councilor Jennings
councilor spenceley
councilor Jennings that's end Spencer
thank you Bill
councilor Stevens thank you councilor
White
uh councilor Jennings please thank you
Council live here
councilor Stevens thank you councilor
fittock
thank you councilor Stevens councilor
Stevens thank you and Jade
councilor Stevens thank you
so um
it's there being blind in my left eye
yeah okay I've got a council Pratt uh
Council Stevens thank you councilor
councilor Stevens Council Ambassador
councilor Stevens thank you very much
indeed I believe that's everybody I've
got
Tara
uh I'll understand thank you
so we've got 13 councilor Stevens
Okay so we've got 13 for councilor
Stevens five for councilor Haywood and
seven for councilor Jennings which means
councilor Haywood drops out thank you
cancer physic
I think the way the process worked you
might want to check with Tava that
because councilor Stevens is a majority
that's the end of it
is yeah it is because she's got so
that's about 13 that was 12 that's over
50 percent yep I believe thank you very
much indeed cancer physic I believe
that's correct so therefore uh councilor
Stevens
is uh is appointed to the Joint
standards committee
thank you membership for indulging me
with that
because
okay we'll do that now just want to
confirm as well that the following
members could um they just confirm that
from the conservative group
um Casa Laban councilor Thompson and
Council within are nominated and accept
and have been appointed
I believe that's the case isn't it okay
District support group Council Neil
thank you liberal Democrat group is
councilor Burwood
okay modern District independent group
is councilor Basinger and councilor
Stevens and we're not aligned we have uh
councilor lay
and we have our non-members an
independent person Mr J.J Mitchell and
two Parish town councilors uh councilor
Davey and Council Stratton okay members
clear on that
okay thank you very much indeed
yep
members what I needed to do is now is to
move to a gender item 11 which is a
German of this meeting so it's to
adjourn the meeting to allow joint
standards committee to proceed to elect
a chairperson and vice chairman special
meeting of the Joyce standards committee
so this is to a to elect a chairperson
of the committee for the remainder of
the municipal year and B to appoint a
vice chairman of the committee for the
remainder of the municipal year so I now
adjourn this meeting at 801
P.M
thank you Tara we now move on to the
special meeting of the joint standards
committee could I ask all members of The
Joint standards committee present in the
chamber please to stand
so that is very conspicuous
cancers
come on screen if that's okay yes please
yep
thank you
good evening gentlemen
can you hear us okay
yeah fine and thanks very much indeed
for joining us this evening thank you
um so I'll Now call for nominations uh
to chairperson of the joint standards
committee for the reminder of the
municipal year uh to May 2024 so please
can a call for nominations for chair
councilor Stevens
I can say it now can't I yes you can
I would like to nominate councilor
Bessinger as chair please
Council Thompson
Kate
nope
you can second it with yep so that
second did any other nominations please
okay so members do you agree that by
Ascent the Council of Passenger is
nominated as a chairperson of the joint
standards committee
yeah
cancer Dave is because you got your hand
up
oh sorry no no that was when you said
stand up
[Laughter]
I think the clarity said those those in
the chamber stand up thank you yeah
we're The Real Slim Shady please stand
up so
that's that's excellent so we've got
that's a council back as you said and
congratulations I'll now hand over to
the chairperson of the joint standards
committee which is councilor Mark
Bassinger
right thank you very much and from the
chair I'd like to ask for nominations
for vice chair and from the chair I
would like to nominate councilor Andrew
lay
thank you
any other nomination sorry
okay then councilor Andrew lay is duly
elected
thank you cheers
okay yeah and having no other business I
closed the meeting of the joint
standards meeting at
804 thank you very much thank you
members please appreciated
um thank you very much indeed
remember just while we're we're close if
any member wishes to move an outer
garment because of the Heat and to make
themselves more comfortable please feel
free to do so
okay item number 12 is a resumption of
business to continue with the business
of the council
the council resumes business at 804 PM
we move on to agenda item 13 which is
the South Eastern planning area planning
committee management this is found on
pages 27 to 32 of the agenda plaque and
Mr Holmes is going to present the report
thank you chairman the purpose of this
report is to review the Southeastern
area planning committee running from the
Burnham on Crouch Town Council offices
and provide options for future setup for
those meetings itself
this report's on from a number of
technical issues we have been managing
during the Southeastern planning
committee meetings and member queries in
July and August
as set out in the report to continue to
deliver meetings as agreed at the Berlin
Town Council Office and with live
streaming this requires further
Financial investment which is why the
matter has been brought back to council
section 3.7 of the report highlights the
current issues being dealt with by
members understanding section 3.8 of the
report then gives three options for
future meetings of this committee
highlighting the positive and negative
impacts for each
you should be noted that for some
options in section 3.8 of the port this
will have a cost implications are set
out any costs would be sought to be
found from existing budgets as far as
possible this year but a drawdown on
resource may be required
the ongoing cost would also add to the
council's overall budget Gap pressures
for the next financial year and onwards
we have been made aware since the report
was published that Burnham it are
looking into Wi-Fi Improvement we have
no guarantee of where this would happen
but discussions with the it is looking
at least to be in four weeks time
regardless of the Wi-Fi Improvement this
would also leave the sound issue to
still be rectified as highlighted in the
report this work has been costed at
approximately six thousand pounds for a
cable system
I'm grateful to Annette cardi and Cheryl
Hughes for researching and drafting of
this report both officers are available
online to assist members with any
questions on the report thank you
chairman thank you very much indeed Mr
Holmes there are two recommendations in
the report there are recommendation
little one that members note the
findings from the review and the issues
set out in section 3.7 of the report and
little two that members confirm the
preferred option for future meetings as
set out in section 3.8 of the report
um do I have a second up
thank you my intention is when we vote I
will take each each individual
recommendation separately so members
Council stamp
um
I do apologize chairman
I take on board everything that's said
in the report
um what I'm going to say is I think it's
quite a biased report this council is
forever trying to move a democratically
elected committee from Burnham on Crouch
that serves approximately eighteen
thousand two hundred members cancer
remember in that division it's about
that isn't it councilor Pratt to
relocate it up here I can understand the
I.T issues but can I change my glasses
I'm speaking and I can't see you
um I understand the IT issues but I've
spoke to Burnham Town councilman I think
um the the chairman of this committee
Southeast planning has also had an email
and I had a catch-up conversation on
Monday with the chief officer and
they're also when you said about the
sound recording Mr Holmes they're
actually looking at a Ultra new I've not
seen it for a long time
um microphone system that goes across
the middle because to me any it happens
here chairman you can actually be
sitting at home and you cannot hear what
some of the members are saying a because
they don't use the microphone properly
so I think there's two separate issues
going on here and I think it is really
unfortunate but yet again that this
cancel and I know who wants to move it
and and I know that and when you move up
here you've still got electric bills
you've still got the um what's his name
the the caretaker and everybody to to
pay and accommodate and you're talking
about
lots of other people most probably
traveling all the way here and that's
not good for your carbon footprint at
all so based on that and if I can come
back after the other members if you'll
allow me just in case
um I would like to propose that we defer
this
um agenda item until Burnham Town
Council has come back with a definitive
because what I raised at the CLT
opposition group leaders meeting last
Friday was that many members don't know
but Burnham Town Council are looking at
and working jointly with Malden District
Council the CCTV operation well we all
know that has to have really good Wi-Fi
and connection for it to operate so
things are a foot and rather than you
know move it straight away is
reactionary and let's say the other
thing the cable wasn't there was using
the Wi-Fi and not hardwired into the I
mean I don't understand this I'm not a
tech Technic person but I know when when
I work from home I hardwire because the
Wi-Fi is not so good when you're at home
and you lose connection so I think if we
could ask you to bear with us a little
bit longer well I'm not a town councilor
anymore but with the town councilors
here
um to not move this committee and if I
can have a second for the recommendation
to defer it thank you councilor Bell
um um I think that would be the way to
go because I think it's fair because I
think otherwise you might have a lot of
people coming and knocking on your doors
thank you thank you Council fluka
I was just looking at this report and uh
and and the amount of people that
attended these meetings
um
um Tim and I I certainly don't recognize
all of those figures there and uh but
certainly the the online views have gone
up because I've actually viewed all of
the committee meetings today so they've
all gone up by one but I don't
understand you know why we're attaching
so much weight to the fact that it's 130
online views because how many of those
are actually at the time there's
absolutely no intelligence there to say
how many people are watching online but
if we can just look at some of the
numbers actually on the 12th of April
there were six persons presence the 25th
of May 16 persons person uh 26th of June
13 people present uh I pick up on 13
people present in relation to item five
and two in relation to agenda six that
last one chairman I I spoke to Burnham
surgery and some of the members there
and I'm satisfied the other ones German
all I've done is look at the tape
counted all the legs in the public
gallery and divided them by two and and
that's why I know those figures are
correct but you cannot you still cannot
see what I won't say what they're called
you can't see where the neck breathers
are because if anyone's been in your and
hopefully I'll be able to welcome you to
a meeting at this Committee in the
future but
um people tend to tuck themselves up in
the corner because they know they can't
be seen on on on on the the sort of the
recording so you know I I would sort of
not add too much weight to those figures
German and some of the costs involved in
this the officers are mentioning uh you
know I think we've got a uh off the top
of my head a level two ICT specialist
who earns forty five thousand pounds a
year and there's a suggestion that he's
going to come to 12 meetings make this
work and that's going to cost us 45 000
pounds a year so perhaps the other four
days he works at home Who would know but
German the numbers don't seem right to
come to this meeting tonight it costs as
much to put this meeting on tonight
excluding officer's time that's what it
would be to put on the Southeast area
planning committee meeting here because
we need a caretaker we need somebody on
reception downstairs and we need I
suspect
I suspect that half of the lights in
here are the equivalent of the lights at
Burnham Town Council so I don't
understand this this footprint business
the carbon footprint I also know that
some of the members if they don't know
Jolly well should the Malden members
should walk to that meeting and and I'm
pleased to see you walking here tonight
chairman so and I think the overarching
thing is Chairman is that is that this
committee has been meeting there since
1974. and according to Bob Boyson I
spoke to today in the center of all his
regards and he's looking forward to
going out with lunch I mean next week
um he said it's been there since the
second world war probably before the
second world from the old bow accounts
or whatever it was so and chairman the
other thing about these figures of
attendance on their own they don't
really say much but I mean I don't know
how many people come to Northwest I
don't know how many people come to
Central but generally speaking we've
always had a lot of people there I think
the people uh in the Southeast area
planning they like it they feel very
remote I think for more than District
Council anyway and and I think chairman
based on that and other things which
I'll bring to the table should this come
back
um I would definitely support uh
councilor stamps proposal to defer this
because
um I was at the Town Council offices
today and just using my basic apparatus
that I had available by logging onto the
system I could hit the upload and the
downloads and the pings and all these
other things which are far in excess of
what's been shown in this report but I'd
leave you all with this thought chairman
when when
when the system broke down last time I
pick up on the time before last when it
broke down last time we sat there and we
sat there and we sat there and the clerk
came out and said
somebody's pulled the wire out and we
poked it back in after hell on 35 40
minutes and bingo it all worked the only
thing that didn't work very well and uh
uh was the sound and that sounds to me
as though they're going to be able to
mitigate that somehow so I look forward
to debasing this again and and I think
that the people in the South residence
in the Southeast area and our businesses
would very much prefer it to stay there
German but I support the recommendation
I hope counselors minded to to defend
thank you very much councilor fluke
that's a very elegantly and long he said
councilor Bell please
thank you I feel like I've been a bit
backward in coming forward as the chair
of this committee but I my esteemed
colleagues have left me very little to
say because they're absolutely right and
I think
be honest as chair of the committee it
has been a nightmare having to deal with
the technical issues it has been
absolute horrendous but having said that
it is about democracy and I think it's
really important we give the Town
Council time and the opportunity to push
forward with what they want to and so I
agree we should defer this thank you
thank you very much councilor Stevens
yeah thank you
against
push back and I I do understand why
people would want to have the meetings
in Burnham but I don't like seeing this
bottomless pit of money being spent so I
think if we were to defer it we should
cease the online streaming at least
until we know we've got a solution in
place or we know we've got a proposal
for a solution we should just stop doing
the online streaming you're not locally
obliged to do it it would save us money
now and give time for a proper solution
to be put in not just something cobbled
together thank you thank you very much
councilor Stevens councilor Thompson
um okay thank you chairman excuse me
um
I'm afraid there are issues with the
online stream I must admit I haven't
watched Southeast planning online for a
little while but the last time I did and
I see no reason to suppose it's changed
there were at least two members of the
committee I couldn't see and I couldn't
tell who they were or I didn't what did
I know when they were who they were when
they were speaking the thump really is
very distracting on the sound and
perhaps that'll change perhaps not but I
found it difficult to hear anything
again that time I think it was a one-off
but on that particular case I couldn't
see the Opera the officer presentation
at all from the online stream so that
that was not adequate so something's got
to change
I can't agree with my colleague
councilor Stevens simply because so many
people more people watch online than
attend so if we stop streaming either
100 people miss out altogether or they
have to shut themselves around the
district to get themselves to burn them
um the point about the people who do
attend is very often applicants we don't
know where they live in the Southeast
area for all but you know some of them
live near a Malden than they do to
Burnham they don't all live in the town
they live in the rural area as well
um I wouldn't be against a deferral but
not an unlimited one
but
and I'm also tradition I'm standing up
not just because I'm sure at the gym
um but just because that's how we did it
after the first after sorry the second
world war and because it was agreed that
it would stay a Burnham forever in 1974.
that isn't a reason to keep them there
it really isn't we do a lot of things
differently now in the country in the in
the district in the towns and
we are short of money we're looking at
going into our reserves very soon and
we've got to save wherever we can this
is not undemocratic it's quite easy to
cope with it thank you thank you Chad
thank you very much indeed because I
said Norman please
um good evening everybody you probably
haven't heard me say anything because
I've been ill
um and but I'm not I'm all right now now
the thing is I was a counselor for 20
for several years on this Council and
also on Burnham Town Council and have
been at planning meetings now we aren't
doing this for us we're doing it for the
residents of Bonham and Mainland and and
southminster and Bradmore and tillingham
and all the people in a dingy
why do we always I mean I don't believe
that it is money that's involved in this
I believe that that for many years now
that you've been trying to stop us
having planning at Burnham
and I really believe at this stage we
have to take ourselves into the the
public and what they want and they don't
want it moved thank you thank you very
much indeed counselor fitted please
uh thank you chat I mean it's still
obviously it's always tempting to try to
find a way to save money personally I
would prefer it here because it sees me
to drive easily depart but I do support
counselor stamps um deferral because
it means a lawful lot to the Town
Council and to the perception of of this
District Council in for the residents in
the area and I think if we if it's look
that we just keep taking things away
because it's going to cost us a little
bit more than we're comfortable with
which is which is obviously with the
wages involved it's considerable but if
there's a way that the staff at BTC can
be gone to a competent level then those
massive I.T costs aren't required in the
first place so obviously if if there's
an upgrade to the system that would
possibly help but I would imagine that
it's entirely possible to do a test on
the day to make sure the system's up and
running I mean when I've done things
I've tested it well before and I'm not
rolled up at 7 30 and then found out the
system doesn't work so I think there's
more work that could be done on it and
if it is MDC that have to um manage that
Focus if there's come in on the day and
do it it doesn't have to be a full-time
job for 10 meetings a year so
councilor bill
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
come back on that councilor fit um a
test is always done during the day of
the meeting the problem is the amount of
traffic that then comes on because it's
a party line called copper party line so
in the day it's absolutely fine in the
evening everyone comes home for work
goes on the computer traffic kicks in
and that's the problem so this is why
they're doing the new tests because
they're going to test do a live test of
an evening and and see what's really
going on so just wanted to clarify that
thank you very much indeed thank you
councilor white
um thank you Mr chairman
um just to say that um as a resident in
the Southeast area
um I think that to move it would
discourage people from attending and
until we go to entirely remote meetings
I think that it's a benefit for the
residents to keep it there and I think
at four thousand pounds a year of all
the money we spend on other items
frankly it's nothing and I think the
only emails I mainly get are about
planning and rubbish bins so I think
those are the two things we would need
to support they're the most contentious
and the things that the residents are
interested in so I support the
application to differ thank you thank
you very much indeed counselor any other
member Council Seattle please
uh thank you Chad I just like officers
to clarify in terms of this item and in
terms of of was agreeing this early in
this year could officers clarify in
terms of the budget that was allocated
at that particular time how much of that
budget has been spent
okay
foreign
thank you chair
um yeah I would have to take that away
and come back I don't have that figure
10 I'm sorry
thank you um a bit Miss cardi
thank you could you get some assistance
thank you
thank you Jeff
a thousand pounds originally
um
additional results
so there's 50 hours
um I've extra I.T time which is about 2
000 and that's all going
thank you very much for the answer your
question Council thank you very much
Casa fluka just one once again I'm
getting a bit confused about all of this
right so let's just talk about what we
call live streams how many times is this
stream we don't know how many people are
live streaming it if we recorded this
meeting and we didn't live stream it we
can still put it on the website and 150
people might look at it
um but chairman based on what Ms cardi
just said I I don't understand this
figure of 50 hours to run to run this
it's 12 it's 12 meetings a year the
occasional one gets counted but one
would have thought that if if somebody
turned up and they found this plug and
they plugged it in I don't know how that
comes to 50 hours a year or was it 275
or 375 pound an hour it just does not
feel right
um so I I do hope that officers will
have taken on board the concerns and
members and their comments tonight so
that when we see this report next time
it's a lot easier to understand and we
fully understand what these costs are
because
um you know I'll have to go to college
to earn 45 for Grant a year for 12
meetings thank you thank you indeed
Council of Luca councilor Thompson
please
thank you chairman it's not actually
part of the debate as such but um
several of us who were meeting the other
day where we did cover this uh I might
need some officer help but we were
informed that in order to record the
meetings even for later uploading
um we do need the software and we need
the Wi-Fi it's not someone sitting in
the corner with a camera we still we
still need the bandwidth excuse me just
to record it not not just a live stream
take care stops a council stamp yeah and
finally chairman
um we I have said that Bernal Crouch is
having CCTV installed to actually
accommodate that they have got to
upgrade their Wi-Fi facilities because
it's so and you know this Richard Holmes
because you're the one who's actually
sent some hopefully you've supported
some of the funding to go to it so we
all know it's going to happen and I and
I'm strongly very I'm strongly very feel
I feel very feel very strong sorry feel
very strongly that we should defer it
and I do think that it's not we're not
going to the Moon are we we're actually
just wanting to stream from Burnham on
Crouch I know that many people don't go
there on a regular basis but it's
beautiful it's better before you go you
don't you go there before you go into
South Minster
um but all I would say is that please
support us to defer it and then we can
readdress it and hopefully I've got
every confidence in Burnham Town Council
and the district council is that here
present to actually represent their
their residence as much as what we do
thank you and I of the members this time
please thank you thank you Council
Stanwell we we actually have we have two
motions we have the original motions
which was seconded and we actually have
the second motion from your good self
which was also seconded the first motion
uh the recommendation we need to vote on
that first and if that fails then we
need to move across onto the proposed
just bear with a sec
okay members just before we we do move
on to the votes which we will have to do
in that time I just missed the home she
wants to raise a point please thank you
chairman obviously if we if members
decide to defer the decision I just
wanted to underline the fact we may
still have technical problems we may not
be able to resolve them so I think that
will be the you know we'll have to live
with that until either the Burnham
connections improve or we reconsider
this matter so I just want to be very
clear on that we'll do the best we can
but it may not be a perfect service
thank you indeed last time councilor
Stevens before we do move to the vote
please
thank you I just I don't think that I've
picked up how long are we deferring this
for because we could spend an awful lot
of money until some other time down the
road I think we need to put a very
strong cap on it we the emotion for
deferral hasn't gone through yet but it
has a stamp what sort of times so it
wasn't finally they meet they meet they
met with the IT guy what day is it today
I think it was yesterday or today and
they're also looking like I said about
doing the microphone which I've never
heard of where it goes down the room on
a wire and all sorts of things so
hopefully the Town Council will be able
to give a report to Richard Holmes or
the district councilors to actually
bring back hopefully for the next
meeting
because you can't meet before cancer
Stephen so
yeah
casatarum thank you well chairman we're
going round around the houses here and I
think there is sufficient
evidence to say that there is work
underway and we don't know the status of
how the how IG system can be improved or
even if it can be improved so I think it
would be unreasonable to make a decision
tonight other than to defer it until we
get further notice if the uh
improvements don't materialize or it
doesn't work then we will know in the
future that it would be quite wrong to
make that decision today thank you
councilor Darren I haven't
um members with regards to vote voting
we've looked at the Constitution and
under section 12 uh which is see we can
actually uh agree to adjourn the debate
which I think will save going through
the vote so if we just adjourn a debate
for this evening I think that's the
fairest way for further information to
be gathered and then the paper can come
back so thank you very much indeed
chairman just as a point of order that
would what point of order are you
calling Council
too thank you
um that would preclude anybody that
um that's not here this evening uh if we
were to adjourn it I mean chairman I I
would think the most simple thing to do
is put recommendations one and two
separately uh I suspect chairman judging
the mood in the chamber one will be
approved to one and then we presume we
can go to councilor stand
and I think that's the fairest way to
allow everybody to take part and can we
have a recording yeah I think for us
experiencing with still some heavy items
on the agenda I am going to stick by
using the Constitution section 12 C to
adjourn well that's very anti-democratic
with respect no that's fine you're
elected to to make comments so that the
the agenda item is deferred okay
painting yeah to join to the next
meeting please Tara thank you
now we've used it in there the correct
is to adjourn the debate not defer it's
a journal debate okay
members we move on to agenda item 14.
which is growth plans for the review of
the local development plan this is to
consider the report of the director of
Service delivery found on pages 33 to 82
of the agenda pack and the officers are
presenting tonight is Mizan old cloth
shortland thank you
good evening members
members am I facing back no no you I can
hear you very clear everybody else okay
I've got a short presentation
absolutely thank you
can everybody say that
you can because you put on presentation
mode
go down the bottom
some members are showing their golden
shot age in the chamber tonight
is that okay can you see that at the
back better members yeah
thank you yeah thanks again
[Music]
so we went out for issue is not
consultation just to recap on from the
17th of January to the 14th of March in
in that issues and options consultation
we had seven high level District growth
options and I'll just quickly run
through them
so option one was business as usual
which was retain the option in the
present approved local development plan
which is focus growth in London
haybridge and Burnham on Crouch
option two is a strong focus on the
towns and larger sustainable Villages
though we didn't name them in the
consultation
option three was Focus growth on Malden
haybridge Vermont Crouch and all the
large villages in the setup settlement
pattern but once again we didn't name
them
option four was pepper potty which is
spread growth around across the whole
District option four was create a new
satellite settlement or a large Urban
extension bolted onto one of the towns
for larger villages
option six was Focus growth in the north
of the district the link into services
in tiptree and winter and maldron and
heybridge so when we say North we mean
north of Cambridge
option seven is focus growth along the
rail line but that's all for north
fanbridge and southminster
so we've had discussions with the
planning policy working group and we've
had two member briefings and we had a
workshop with members on the in July of
this year
there are some other things
and you've gone quiet with apologies
can you hear me now yep thank you
when we're working on growth options and
what we're going to do once the plan
period and we have had discussions about
this last year through the policy
working group and strategy and resources
and I think it went to council as well
and we came to the conclusion a 20-year
plan is is probably appropriate because
it gives us a long lead-in time for
infrastructure which then allows US
economies of scale in terms of funding
infrastructure
we need to consider the district
district housing requirement
um
when we do modeling at this stage of of
the process we model the top line so you
look at what you need you may need and
you'd see what you could need and you
when you're doing a modeling your model
top loan and it was raised with the
members on Tuesday that we will also
model the bottom line as well
of the housing requirement and the
reason we do that is one we have to
model flexibly
two
part the top line is we you know County
Council have said we need a secondary
school so to pay for that Secondary
School we're going to need four and a
half thousand houses and ten hectares of
land so we have to build that into the
modeling so we'll have to emphasize
that at the present time that's only Top
Line modeling and there could be other
infrastructure costs that we have to
model and uh mitigate against and I'm
particularly talking about Highway
litigation here because that will
probably come it was the largest cost
s huh part of the work is we're going to
be doing a transport a transport
modeling across the district against the
options if the if you're minded to
approve them today so we have to model
at the Top Line
the maximum because whether you
whether you look at 2 000 houses or
twenty thousand houses the cost of the
transport modeling is the same and we
have to take that into consideration
because it's around a hundred thousand
pounds
so we really only want to do this piece
of work once we don't want to be
defending I put an examination and being
sent back to then redo modeling that we
should have done in the first place so
that's why
that's where the housing requirements
through the auctions looks really large
though it probably won't end up like
that at the end of the day
we have to look at the district district
affordable housing requirement so at the
moment it's setting the local housing
needs assessment which was done in 2021
it's 172 per annum which is
3414 over 20 years and what we have to
do is we have to try and provide that
requirement through the auctions and
where we we know we can't councils can't
do that it's very very difficult but
what you have to do is just try best
basically and then demonstrate that the
examination
we need we need to know we've got enough
land in in the options to satisfy our
input infrastructure provision in terms
of site size and also economies of scale
how we're going to provide not just
schools but there's hospitals there's
Highway provision there's on-site
provision as well so allotments
Landscaping biodiversity all the other
things that come with with growth
um small size it's a national
requirement that 10 of our sites need to
be under a hectare in size so we need to
make sure there's enough sites in the
options to provide that requirement
there isn't
they're too they're too big
um the sites that have come forward and
even if we put existing commitments in
with that 10 we still can't make 10 We
Will We Will monitor that
um but so what that's actually doing as
we get you know we it's actually forcing
us to think about all the info policy
which we will be discussing with members
at a later date
Brownfield now there's hardly any in the
district it's it's negligible it's it's
not even worth counting but what we will
say is if when we actually do come to
site applications if there's a
Brownfield site
we will take that one first in the
settlement rather than the Greenfield
site so um you know that that's good
practice to do that and flood risk
um we've got a new uh strategic flood
risk assessment we're just waiting for
some comments back from angling water
and environment agency but that will
assist us when we are looking across
both the settlements and sites going
into the future and it'll also help us
when we delve down into these little
options
so we asked a number of questions around
the options it's sort of a high level
appraisal that helps us give a a picture
of them in a way and we did it through a
rag analysis which is red and green So
and I've just basically gone through
them can the can the option deliver the
land requirement and we've looked at the
top line for that because the other
thing is we want to have
a broad choice of sites if you don't if
you don't look across a broad choice of
sites you're actually being squeezed
into what you've what you are going to
allocate and you know we don't want that
we want to have choice
can the option deliver 10 on site
smaller than
less than a hectare well we we know that
none of them can do that
can the option deliver the land for a
secondary school so has it got sites
that can deliver 10 hectares of land
from school
can the option deliver economies of
scale to deliver other infrastructure
can affordable housing be delivered
could the option offer a provider
improve sustainable travel options so is
it in a place that could do that could
the option offer fire to improve enough
sustainable locations to accommodate
growth and with the option support the
sustainable functioning of essential
services like Health Access to emergency
services so that's the people who drive
around the district midwives Social
Services elderly persons care you know
that can it support them or is it going
to squeeze on their capacity to deliver
their services
so if I turned to a summary of option
one which is business as usual so that's
put growth in the settlements of mold
and haybridge and burn them on Crouch so
carry on doing what we're doing today
so
the auction on its own can't deliver the
land requirement in order to to deliver
enough choice of sites it can't deliver
the 10
it can there is a sorry in that option
to deliver a secondary school there is
enough land
but can it offer the economies of scale
to deliver other infrastructure that we
need well that's doubtful because there
isn't enough land to deliver the option
in the first place it can't deliver the
affordable housing Target
it is a sustainable option I mean
there's you know there's there's no
denying that putting your growth in your
most sustainable basis is is sustainable
the towns offer the services
sustain every day every day life
um
in terms of in terms of location you
know it's a good location in terms of
access to Services that's really good
so there's a map of the um of the
options we've got maldon
and burn them on Crouch and haybridge
I've just gone through
the rag analysis
so it might be appropriate to combine
this option with one or two others to
get the scale and choice of sites
so option two
was a strong focus in the town's and
larger sustainable Villages which we
which we didn't name but actually the
larger Villages the larger sustainable
villages in order of size are
southminster tailsbury Mayland and
latchington so that's the top four
the one underneath that we can bishops
so that would be the top five uh larger
villages
option three
Focus growth in the town's modern
haybridge and Burnham and all the large
villages in the settlement pattern which
you really and truly is a merger of
options one and two
that means that the large villages in
the settlement pack now South Mr
tollsbury Mayland lutchington Wickham
Bishops tillingham Tolson Darcy
and great Tottenham South so they would
be included in that option
so in regard to those
those two that they can deliver the land
um or for the for their housing
requirement they can't deliver 10 but
that's not
I can deliver the lounge for a secondary
school
and they can deliver the economies of
scale in terms of the the other funding
the cards deliver the affordable housing
requirement but it's probably not that
far off
option two I mean they are sustainable
locations and you know they could offer
sustainable
um locations to accommodate that growth
and they could they could help the
services that move around the district
for option three we've given Amber or
could it improve sustainable travel
options and access to Services because
you are moving out wider across the
district
now just out just because people say oh
we're all putting all the growth in the
North in the South uh four of those
settlements are in the north and four in
the South so there's quite an even
spread across options Road
there's options right so you've got
Burnham or Crouch Moulton and haybridge
then if you have the four largest
Villages South Mr tollsbury Maitland and
Lexington and then you would add the
fifth one in which is Wickham Wickham
Bishops if you wanted to go to five
and then that's all of the large
villages
so option four is petal potting so
that's spread growth across the whole
District
um
it doesn't mean that you'd get some kind
of fair distribution of the growth
because in order to accommodate the land
you probably have where where the sites
are basically and then you choose from
all the sites so you'd kind of have a
kind of almost a site Choice best about
where you would go but
yes it can deliver all the land that
that's you know quite clearly Cloud
because it covers all of the site all of
the settlements in the district
it can't deliver the small site it's not
so even if you take all the sites that
have been put in you still can't deliver
the small the small cap science can to
live with the land for a secondary
school there's a number of sites there
so I won't
could it offer the economies of scale to
deliver other infrastructure well that's
debatable because if you spread your
growth around of course you're spreading
your cost per infrastructure around so
it may be that no we it couldn't deliver
the economies of scale this one can
deliver the affordable and Target
but would that affordable housing be in
the right place well that's another
another question
could the option provide an improved
sustainable travel options well no it
couldn't because we're spreading it
right across the whole District we would
have to pay for a transport
travel strategy if we chose this option
or something that we haven't budgeted
for in order to justify why why why you
wouldn't have this option and why it
would be then sustainable
would the option support the function of
essential Services well no no it
wouldn't and actually we've had
objections on this option from health
and the County Council because their
services travel around and it would
Place pressure on their services and the
capacity of their services to be
delivered
so if we spread it all around and I
haven't included in the small villages
in this but actually if there's land in
smaller Villages they would be included
so option five was create a new
satellite settlement no there is no land
lodging enough for us to do that it
hasn't come forward it's just not big
enough
so what we would actually have is a
large larger Urban extensions bolted
onto one of the towns larger Villages
and or settlement adjacent to the
district's boundary
um
had the option to live with the Atlanta
Club not on its own it can't no
um it's not far off but it can't do that
can't deliver the 10 sites because
obviously these are the largest sites
that have come forward
could the land to live could the option
deliver the land for secondary school
yet yes yes it can
can it uh offer economies of scale we've
made this Amber because there is
question mark about that because if you
have lots of really massive sites then
perhaps the infrastructure in other
places can't be provided or perhaps
there isn't it it all it all goes onto
the site and not the other side
can you can the affordable housing be
delivered by this option no it no it
can't
um does it offer sustainable travel
options possibly yes it possibly does
because it depends where they where they
are and how that links into other travel
options
um
and it improve or provide sustainable
locations to accommodate growth that's
that's an Amber because we don't really
know yet because we haven't really done
any work on on these and it depends
where where the sites are
in turn that's would be the same about
essential Services it's an Amber because
we haven't really done the work yet on
it
so
there are so it's large enough in Lawton
and haybridge all Thorn adjacent to the
boundary of Southwood of pharaohs
southminster uh I've got Burnham on
there but I don't think there is a site
largely nothing Burnham
um so there's land for so please number
so Jason boundary of the South Woodham
Ferris there's a site in Old Thorne
which you could accommodate 750 homes
there's sites in London which could
accommodate 1600 pounds the site is
Southeastern which could accommodate a
thousand times but we're still short in
terms of this option on its own it would
have to be combined with another option
and of course we would have to consider
a win for policy for the 10 off sites on
land less than the hectare
so option six
Focus growth in the north of the
district to link into the services and
Facilities available in tipture in
Witham a molten and hay Bridge
there is not the land
of this requirement not not nearly
enough actually and there's probably
because of the type of land and I think
a lot of that is relation to the great
Braxton Park sort of is in the way 200
hectares of the north is taken up with
that side
um so there's definitely not enough land
you know even when we start putting it
with some some of the other options
there's not enough land so of course we
couldn't deliver 10 of the sites
um on sites less than a hectare
there's no site big enough
it couldn't deliver the economies of
scale to deliver the infrastructure that
we possibly need couldn't deliver the
affordable housing Target and really
wouldn't provide sustainable travel
options in terms of a location I mean
the the sites are linked into tip tree
and Britain and modern haybridge so you
know they they could be quite
sustainable in terms of that that that
particular Factor
but we would have to test that and could
this would it support for sustainable
essential of essential Services well
that's probably debatable because there
isn't enough land in the first place to
accommodate the the growth
the issue with this particular
um so there's the four large villages
um in the North
the issue with this particular
option is it's the only option that
highways
um England actually the highway
Authority no
the national highway Authority objected
to because of the impact on the a12 and
the um the work that's going on there
because it's been modeled not on lots
and lots of growth in the north of
Malden the other thing is
if we start impacting on the services
then tick tree and witton they're
already planned for so any additional
growth that we have up in the north
we would then have to pay off after sale
or section 106 money would probably be
shipped out to tip through Whitton to
pay for the infrastructure that we're
creating in the north of the district so
that is but if that could be an issue
but the main issue is that there's just
not enough land and
so and even if we come started to
combine option six with another option
so if we combine it with option one that
still isn't enough land and then once
you start combining it with
um two or three you're then going back
into option two or three so
but option seven is focus broken on the
railway the railway line too so that's
all Phil North Banbridge for South
Minister and we've included Burnham on
Grouch in this
we didn't originally in the original
edition of issues and options we we
didn't have Burnham in this option
because we wanted to test the
consultation responses because what we
said was there is a gap in
infrastructure provision but the
consultation responses have not
supported that particularly from the
penalty they wanted to know what we were
going on about
so until we've got the evidence to
support that then we feel that it's
appropriate to leave Burnham on crouch
in this auction because part of the work
is to gain the evidence to see if there
really is a gap in infrastructure
so this option all on its own can't
deliver the last requirements you can't
deliver the 10 sites uh there is land
for a secondary school in this option
but it probably on its own it could
deliver the economies of scale
um to fund infrastructure including the
secondary school can't provide the
affordable housing is it is it a
sustainable no you know that does it
provide a sustainable uh travel options
and we we did have a debate on Tuesday
but remember briefings about this
and we've given it an Amber now the idea
is that you would test this because it's
relating to the railway line and we
don't know how effective that is and
what we would have to do is we would
have to do a piece of work which
actually we started
yesterday
to look at the railway line in a lot
detail and then we would have to provide
a topic paper so what what is it about
that Railway line
what sort of capacity is it got who's
using it
how much is it going to cost to improve
there's a whole series of questions
around this option that we would then
have to work on in terms of that Railway
line so that's why that's been given
um in in terms of sustainable
medications once again it it's an Amber
because you know at the end of the day
on paper this option looks like a really
good option because again it's got the
railway line it can be linked into
climate change but we don't know the
answers to the questions about
um sustainability and the same with the
functioning of essential services
so
what happens next if you're blinded to
approve these options we will be doing
a lot of work on them I mean huge
amounts of work
we need to carry out the transport
modeling on the options because we need
to know
what condition the highway is we need a
baseline for the highway we need to look
at the top line for growth and we need
to look at the bottom line which members
are raised in the in the briefings that
we had on Tuesday and that was a good
idea to look at the bottom line as well
um
because we need to know in terms of
Transport what do we need to do in order
to mitigate any impact and how much is
it going to cost and is it actually
visible or affordable so if you go back
if I just go back
to this one option seven
when we're looking at transport more
today you know we're going to be going
along the lower burn road we need to
know what the impact of that is how much
is that going to cost in order to
mitigate and it may be that
um you know at the end of the day the
costs of mitigation of mitigating harm
from from the options and from the
growth is so great
that we can't overcome it so because if
you think about the district there's
only so many ways we can get in and out
of it
and um there's issues every everywhere
we turn
so part of the transport modeling is to
to work that out we'll be looking at
flood risk as well in terms of our new
strategic blood pressure
flood risk assessment will be looking at
quality biodiversity green
infrastructure the water cycle will be
doing infrastructure appraisals with
education transport and health
we'll be getting it over the sights
again like crawling over the sides
literally
um in detail and we'll be compiling
evidence in order to then come back to
members to make an informed choice about
what direction they want to go to and
we'll use that evidence to challenge and
test those options but what we can also
do is use that evidence in terms of
providing our own evidence we're
planning applications come in and it's
also obviously built after school and
thank you very much I think if you could
just finish on a summary because it's a
very comprehensive short paper
I want to be really clear about what
this is not okay what we are not voting
on today is we're not voting on the
housing requirements okay we're not
setting the housing requirement for the
district this is just modeling we're not
choosing site allocations that's not
what we're voting on today and
um
these options do not carry any weight
when we're determining planning
applications that's much further on down
in the process so what we're actually
voting on today is yeah I think that the
thing with Sean thank you very much
we've actually got the recommendations
in the report and for experience of time
and we've got the details so I thank you
greatly for the the detail that you put
in there
um members there are five
recommendations are found on page 33 and
just to be mindful that there's a note
should the report not be agreed the
following amount of business which is a
gender item 15 the update on the local
development scheme will need to be
deferred because the timetable of the
local development plan would have to be
reassessed now I was minded first of all
with the options because we've got five
recommendations to go through each
recommendation individually to vote upon
both Phil with the comprehensive
presentation of the officer just now I
feel it will be advantageous to look I
need to read them out obviously as
members understanding what the
recommendations are
um and then to open the floor to debate
and then take a vote on them in whole so
members there are five recommendations
they are one um pursue further testing
for option three growth generally
focused on the towns of modern haybridge
and birnamon Crouch and all the large
villages in the settlement pattern level
two pursue further options testing for
option five a large Urban extension
bolted onto the existing settlements in
the district and adjacent to the
District boundary in combination with
option three growth generally focused on
the towns of Malden and haybridge and
Burnham on Crouch and all large villages
in the settlement pattern little three
pursue further testing options for
option seven Focus growth along the
railroad line or Thorne Berman on Crouch
North fanbridge and southminster in
combination with option one retain the
option in the ldp approved in 2017 Focus
growth in Malden haybridge and Burnham
on Crouch is part of option seven
recommendation for is not pursue option
for Pepper Pot growth through the
settlement pattern spread growth across
all the sustainable develops in the
district and option five not pursue
option six Focus growth in the north of
the district to link into the services
and Facilities available in tip tree
with a Malden haybridge do I have a
second the members
second that counselor Pratt thank you
very much indeed members councilor White
please
Mr chairman you think you indulge me
because I have to leave shortly I should
have actually left by now so I'm going
to make where I'm meant to be going
um my I've got lots of problems with
this
um and I'm speaking as a ward member for
um Hurley
and it seems to be everybody likes the
railway line
um but um if you go into the Natural
England Publications
um under the national character areas
map
it falls on the area 81 which is the
greater Tim's history and under the
statements of environmental
opportunities it's maintained and
enhance the expansive remote Coastal
landscape sc03 ensure the Tranquil and
remote character of the Estuary and the
key characteristics are predominantly
flat low-lying Coastal Landscapes where
extensive Open Spaces are dominated by
the sky with open Mosaic habitats
now we then move on to the regulating
coastal flooding and erosion and the
shoreline management plan and the
corruption wrote estuaries come under
ramzar triple SI sac and Spa and there
are five boundary features and patterns
most of which are the ditches and
waterways
um but when you go into and focusing
development along that Railway line
would destroy them they'll destroy the
view
um and they destroy the habitats but
more than that under the shoreline
management plan we come under area eight
which is the Crouch and you've got H3
h2bh2a and H1
h2a which is all Thorn to Burnham
um and then you've got Bridge Marsh has
managed realignment which means flood
and also no active intervention
intervention in the first Epoch which
runs out in 2025. any one which is h2b
north fanbridge there's no active
intervention the others are currently
hold the line but of course these always
change and you also look into it's a
miso climate in Hawthorne and that means
it's a special climate particularly for
growing Vineyards I know for a fact that
a lot of The Vineyards in France are
actually now buying land in our district
because it's too hot and too dry there
to actually produce good grapes so I
don't know what they need to grow grapes
or whatever it is they haven't got it
um so that's a bit of a problem then I'm
also going to move on to um the traffic
and the final option which is or the
option here we go which one's it wanna
go there are two here
um it's the one option five which is the
new satellite well it could be any
Western area I see that my ward is
included but this is where I think we
put in the cart before the horse because
we're talking about a thousand houses
couple of thousand houses whatever it
might be but have we been in discussion
with this it's County council with how
much money we need to get to get any
bypasses because there's several
thousand houses going in Woodland Ferris
and I can assure you there is no Road
upgrades everything going from the south
the district has to go on the lower
Burnham Road there is nothing proposed
um we're talking about the health of the
schools with more of the pinch points
um so have we spoken to transport East
one of those talks planned
um and I mean we've already got the
bypass in Malden that's supposed to be
taking place and it if I've been made
aware that Essex County Council looking
to buy some land off the land I wanted
to build some houses there presumably to
fund that bypass which hasn't yet
happened now I presume officers have
been talking to Essex County Council and
they can confirm whether that's true or
not because with rumors they can be true
or they might not be true I don't know
for sure
um but we you know also into that let's
look at
um bulia Park boulia Park new railway
station and new bypass but this is
County Council highways miscalculated
the cost of the bypass there's going to
be no Bypass or there might be bits of
it but we're not giving the bypass so
for me we're too far ahead looking at
what we're going to do until we get firm
answers on Essex County Council and what
they are or are not doing I don't see
how we can even look into these options
it's a waste of money so I mean I I
think we should go to the County Council
see what they're going to do
um my other fear with the railway line
is there's land in southman's been put
forward for a secondary school would
this mean that all the
um towns along that Railway line
Wickford wooden fairies and everywhere
else if they've got problems with school
places which I know they have could they
bust their children from their areas
into our schools so is it going to help
us in in bearing in mind the actual
traffic problems on the lower Burnham
Road
um so and lastly it looks like option
four pepper potting well I'm in a rural
Ward we need small amounts of housing so
that younger parents or younger children
can look up be looked after by their
grandparents that the parents of the
younger children can then help to look
after their parents there's a
grandparents their little children when
they become old and infirm like we used
to do in our Villages
um so really I think it's assurances
with have we been engaging already with
this County Council because if we
haven't why are we looking at the
options until we see and my final thing
is why is nothing going in the north why
is it all in the South I know that
you're still in one of the meetings that
the Farmland in Essex was worthless and
sat in the south of the district was
worthless and that you wanted the um
Nate to go to the north because I
practice park or somewhere but you know
what we are important our land's
important and I think you know yes it
might be we lose some if we can start
out the road infrastructure but we need
to do the road infrastructure first so
have we spoken to us it's County Council
what's their policy what's their funding
have we spoken to transport East is
anything planned I've been told they're
going to do nothing in our district
because it's not on the top of their
list because you have to apply for
funding
um the housing one more thing how's
housing south of Lambert way when we
agreed that in the last ldp we were
promised to bypass what's the one thing
we haven't got because all the housing
no bypass so that their things have we
done this yet and I'm gonna have to run
I'm really sorry
thank you very much does any officer
wish to comment there's a lot of
questions and some statements there Mr
Winslow
and please
most of the work that councilor white
has talked about will be done once we
choose the three options
we can't start the work without reducing
the options down from seven to a much
lower number because the other statutory
providers will not engage with us
because there's two too many options and
it's too costly for them to do that we
can't do transport modeling on seven
high level options because just to
option just a transport model three
options is going to cost a hundred
thousand pounds so if we start transport
modeling seven options you can imagine
that the cost would then you know spiral
out control so most of us most of the
items that she's talked about we will
look at in detail when we do our work
um on those options and then we will
bring that back to members now with
regard to the smaller settlements in the
next item I have put an additional piece
of work in for us to look at what I call
single plot exceptions in the smaller
settlements and I've heard what members
have said about the smaller settlements
and we will discuss that with members
going forward into the future you know
what what we can do because we don't
have to strategically allocate in the
smaller settlements and you know as far
as I'm aware they don't want strategic
allocations so you know we will chat to
members about that in the future they
won't forget them thank you very much
indeed counselor Burwood please
thank you chairman I recognize and I
Echo the passion for the South that
councilor white has but of course I'm
going to have it for the north
um what really concerns me is a really
big flaw in that
paybridge is being seen as a suburb of
Malden and in one case and I think it's
uh little two it's referred to as the
towns of Malden and heybridge heybridge
is a village with its own separate
identity we may only be a fact papers
whipped away from Alden but we are
completely separate identity with a
completely separate and different uh
population and that needs to be
recognized as well we've had a lot of
building work going into hybrid recently
um with a little bit of infrastructure
hopefully if it all comes off but we
cannot we we must remember that Malden
and hainbridge are two completely
different parts of our district
thank you councilor Burwood any other
member wish to speak on this matter
councilor Darren please
well thank you chairman and I've said
this before
yeah I still maintain that we have been
and are still premature with this
to date
61 authorities that's 20 percent of
every LPA in the country has delayed
updating their ldp due to changing Mass
potential change in National planning
policy up till September last year 19
had done it and a further 42 authorities
have stopped it this year and I'm afraid
we've already heard the potential cost
of carrying out some of this modeling we
are potentially throwing money away by
pursuing it and I've said it all along
we should be waiting until we know what
the the planning environment is going to
be with the update of the nppf as I said
20 percent that's a fifth of all lpas in
the country have stopped doing the same
work as we're doing thank you thank you
councilor Darren uh councilor fitted
please and then cancel the bill
um
oh
thank you I'd like to further page 35
3.5 and 3.6 of the report
um in that it's indicating that
Supply that we have now
will suddenly disappear because we built
it well my understanding of a locally
development plan is it starts from a
point and ends at a point and the start
point is 2023 and the end point is 2043
so whatever happens with build out when
the plan is adopted that will just be
referred back to starting from 2023 2024
2025 that's what they do so at the
moment we actually have around about 3
100 houses left to build
so in essence the modeling is going to
add another
6680 to that number so I'd firstly like
to know are we going to be modeling on
9758 or whatever it is or just the 665a
because there's obviously going to be a
cumulative effect we've still got three
thousand one under the build
um so I'm not sure you know what numbers
we're working for Mateo because it in
principle
as I say to fulfill a plan requirement
for 20 years
it's two four five the problem is really
what we're saying is that we need to
increase the amount of houses we build
to fund the school place by 4 500 and
that would require the district to
increase to do that it's it's built up
right to about 450 per year over the
20-year period
if we were to look back a step when we
did the consultation the consultation
indicated that we need to build for that
we needed land for
4492 houses that was a year two to a
couple of years back but that also
included a 20 buffer with that 20 buffer
doesn't need to be built that's just to
give you choice of land so given that
we've now got 2 458 to find to in
principle for getting buffers
um fulfilled 20 years alone I wondering
how Essex County Council would view that
much different number
if we were to to take a step back before
that it was deciding to go to a 15-year
plan to or the choice was 15 year old
20-year plan at the moment if we were to
go to a 15-year plan with the land
Supply we've got we need about a
thousand more houses of land Supply now
I suspect that by the time we get to if
we do move forward this to a
presentation of the plan the officers
will have approved that thousand houses
anyway so in principle we will be in a
position where we could have not have
done the work because we've approved the
houses anyway apart from the extra five
that we need the extra five that we need
have actually meant we've had to build
another 4 500 houses that we might not
have had to build in the first place the
problem we've got is is because I was
right to a degree
it's all been squashed into a very short
space of time and and that's the problem
I don't really have a problem with the
modeling
um because it will just tell us what we
already know in principle that we're not
going to be able to achieve this
objective but I do think the other work
we need to probably go back and take a
closer look at it because the
Situation's considerably changed since
the consultation and I'm not entirely
sure that I know there'll be
complications with um affordable housing
if we were just to use existing land
because it's not as companion should be
but we're so far in front I know people
say we haven't got five years so that's
all about how you do it we've actually
approved as a council 1200 houses more
than we need to fulfill a local plan
requirement
now we've approved 5900 our plan
requirement was 4650 and that's part of
the problem because we're just going to
have growth upon growth upon growth and
we'll end up really with two plans
running we'll have the back end of this
plan finishing as the start of the new
plan starting which is why we'll end up
with about 450 houses per year as a
housing Target so but the main thing is
to understand how you measuring this all
out because it it's not what we need
it's what we need to build a school
so physics I was missing me before I
come to councilor bill that I didn't go
back to miss all told shawland to answer
councilor Durham's question and then
there's obviously questions that has
been raised by councilor fitick so um
and if you've come in and comment please
right I went to
a conference Now by D Lock and a
planning advisory service
as they were talking about uh continuing
plan making and I
because the plans planning system is
changing so if you can't submit your
plan by the 25th of June
2025 you will move into the new system
that's now a definite that is going to
come out
we will not be able to do
I don't think we're going to be able to
make that that date
so we will be
in the news my question today
amongst a group of councils
that will not make the date the deadline
date but we will be near we will be very
near we won't be far off at all actually
with a fair wind we will probably be out
to Preferred options or maybe even have
a draft plan but we won't be able to
submit so I said well what were we going
to do what what what is going to happen
to us and their reply was you must keep
the planning because most of the work
that you're doing is actually going to
be needed in the new system anyway
and that for those group of councils
like ourselves we will get help from the
planning advisory service indeed look to
make sure that we can fit ourselves into
new system without any additional kind
of cost or work so they'll help us if we
stop planning
we won't have that help and we will
still have to do the work the work that
we're talking about today the transport
modeling and all that we will still have
to do that because that applies to the
new system just as much as it applies to
the system that we have now and there's
strong advice and it's the advice that I
would also give you is we should
continue plant making thank you very
much indeed I moved to cancel the bill
please
thank you and counts the white touched
on some of the environmental stuff you
know the importance of the countryside
the importance of the salt marsh
which is you know and all the ssris and
the ramsar areas
but some talking of climate certainly be
underwater by 2050 all this um option
whatever it is the Crouch Valley if you
look at the climate modeling
um it's not looking too great for our
area and large swathes of it mostly the
options that we want to pursue not going
to be there anymore
but also we keep piling stuff on Burnham
don't we just piling developer
development after development
and I'm interested what these facilities
are I mean we've just spent a couple of
weeks without any cat working cash
points in the sound they've tightened
barbecules out they've took Tesco's out
they put it back in and the little ones
you get in the shops they don't work so
you know can't get money out unless you
queue up at the post office we've got a
school that's over subscribed we've got
doctors we might not have a doctors
pretty soon the way things are going
looks like we're actually having
infrastructure taken out
so I just it just seems like we're going
for
the easy options which aren't the best
options and you know yeah there's a
train line let's stick stuff there
because it's sustainable no it's not not
if it's going to ravage the countryside
and destroy you know destroy areas that
we need and if we're going to miss out
on um money we could get for local wine
then I'm not happy about that so I just
think yeah I'd like us to stop and think
really thank you thank you very much
indeed members we've had quite a robust
presentation ah okay two hands are going
up at once so Council lafluka please
Kevin I've I've spent past this
afternoon looking at the generic
election addresses or the members here
so I'd be very interested to see how
they're going to vote but um chairman
I'm I'm really concerned I mean it's
quite interesting there's been some very
interesting motions come forward to this
Council
uh in the past 18 months concerning the
local development lab and and I tried to
put them in the summary today and it's
quite interesting but I do feel that if
some of them if some of the members have
been brave and supported those
um then we probably would have been in a
much better place today but if when I
put them together I'll certainly
circulate those
um
when Miss shortland responds to my
questions
um perhaps the first one uh she could
respond to is a point of clarity in
relation to southminster she says that
there is a site for a thousand houses in
southminster
um I think I'd like to know where that
what is because I looked at the Healer
and the call for sites and I can't see
that but one thing I would say is one
development in the South Minister has
already been refused uh another one they
don't think they can mitigate highways
issues and the third one which is the
most is the most concerning one chairman
is being brought forward by a major uh
National healths Builder
um who is basically saying that their
site was identified in the Healer and
because of that it's been endorsed by
the the policy team
um I don't know how much weight to give
to that comment but what I would say is
this and this is an extract chairman
it's very important from a from a an
appeal decision and it says an
additional factor is the assessment made
under under the council's call for site
process the the assessment
seems to have clearly concluded that in
principle it would be acceptable for
development so we have a bit of a
problem there and unfortunately those
same comments are echoed in the cost
decision and I'll be looking forward to
engaging with 151 officer to find out
how much those costs were because four
costs were awarded in that so that's one
thing that that concerned me
um
and also chairman it
this business about Villages and
sustainability I mean members would have
all seen today the the appeal decision
there were several today so who sold the
one at London chairman I wonder but a
planning inspector ruled today that
London which if you blink you miss it
is a sustainable location
I came through there tonight gen four
Street lamps and 100 meters of footpath
no shots no schools no doctors they've
got a boozer I suppose
um but that is a sustainable location so
I really don't know why we're
discounting all of these chairman
um and as far as this secondary school
is is concerned I think Miss Miss
Shoreland said that
one of the sites in one of the options
could bring forward the land to build
the secondary school my feeling is
Chairman that that well my understanding
is Chairman that a developer has
contacted the council and has said that
they do have the land to do that which
would be interesting but I think one of
the most one of the biggest risks in
this and you know even based on Council
of physics optimism of numbers and where
they should really be as opposed to
where they are
um one of the biggest risks I see here
is the fact that we could take the
houses but not get the secondary school
and that the secondary school goes
across the border which means we've then
got the added problem school buses uh
you know going going down the low of
Burnham road every year so we need every
day so we need to be very very careful
with this
um chairman I I my election address
chairman is imprinted
on my mind and uh in the memory of the
residents of South Minton I'll be I'll
be voting accordingly on what's In My
election dress thank you chairman thank
you very much Miss Sean and I'll talk
shawl in many comments on councilor
um Lucas points
[Music]
the pictures
two thousand houses can you speak a bit
louder please yeah we've had your model
on the top line perhaps we have to so if
we know what we what we know the County
Council told us we need a secondary
school so we need to model for that now
it doesn't mean that the modeling is
going to be successful or or that we're
going to end up with that many houses
because there could be so many
constraints and so many costs
but in the end we can't accommodate that
level of growth and it may be that we'll
have to go to our neighbors and ask them
to accommodate our growth for us but
until we leave no stone unturned and
we've signed up to a pan Essex agreement
on this we have to leave no stone
unturned and that means we have to model
to the Top Line we have to try and
accommodate our growth try and
accommodate our infrastructure
so at the moment we don't have any
evidence to suggest we have no transport
modeling because the last transport
model was done what 2008 2010 and 2013
so it's well out date we have no
evidence to support that our district
can't accommodate growth we need to do
the modeling in order to work it out and
you know we can't
go to an inspector examination and say
well actually we don't think the
district can accommodate growth and with
no evidence so we start the Top Line
model evidence look at things like flood
risk which is what the councilor Bell
was talking about we'll look at real
detail drill down
and then we'll come back to you members
with all of the information and then you
can make an informed judgment about what
you want to do so at the moment we're
not setting the housing requirement all
we're doing is working out with what
this District can accommodate
thank you very much indeed councilor
Thompson please
thank you very much
um
yeah I'm going to say something I
suspect nobody wants to hear but we
probably all agree with
the look of any of the options very much
we
've more
well we're a small rural District as a
matter of fact it doesn't matter whether
you're a member for a rural reward or a
town or a village or whatever you've got
the vast majority of the residents live
here because they like it the way it is
we we were
an area of was it planning restraint for
decades and it sounds so quaint and
wonderful but what it actually meant was
we've never got any infrastructure
I mean I don't see that we can do
anything other than look at the best
we've got and do the best we've got with
it and for that reason I I support the
officer's views on these recommendations
that doesn't mean I have to like them
all because
I don't but there isn't an option as she
has just spelled out there isn't an
option of saying well we don't like the
look of this we don't think we should
have so much housing we've got to do the
work we have to do the work it's a shame
but there you go thank you thank you
very much indeed Council stand
um thank you chair
um I can just see the headlines on
Facebook tomorrow morning District
Council wants to get rid of Southeast
planning in Burnham but you're going to
get an extra five thousand houses
because you need a new school just see
it and it's going to tag me in Wendy
stamp your comment yeah so hopefully
they won't do that because they're going
to listen to the rest of the debate
um but I've actually can I just bear
with me I just want to read I got an
email and I think councilor Bell got the
same email I won't read it all and it
says I'm incredulous that one of these
option seven is even on the table given
its resounding lack of public support at
the recent consultation exercise this
option is possibly the most destructive
thing that could happen to the Crouch
belly short of a major natural I
shouldn't say that major natural
disaster it's frankly ludicrous for the
officers to even develop the idea
especially given MDC stated climate
emergency reference councilor Bell even
should sufficient infrastructure I like
this even should sufficient
infrastructure be put in place to
support it unlikely concreting over the
slopes will ruin the natural Coastal
landscape for the Millennia I think that
actually sums it up really I I think you
know I'm getting quite worried because
Burnham and Crouch seems to be so
popular in every option but I think one
and I also have a lot of sympathy for
haybridge
Malden I'm sorry I don't have a lot of
sympathy for you've got one more field
you can build on to actually join it all
up for the for the relief road but in
all seriousness chairman if we keep
building we're gonna keep growing you
build the houses people will come
everybody knows that I'm a great
advocate for infrastructure we know we
haven't had that infrastructure and at
one of the meetings um and you know I
raised it and turned around and she said
well you're getting saturated if you
read the current ldp it said burner on
Crouch sufficient for its own needs at
450. now because this Council wouldn't
cap it and they didn't say it was a
maximum they kept saying everything yeah
cancer Thompson are you going to say it
was a minimum I was watching I caught
you at the side of my eye um it's the
minimum sometimes you have to say things
are a maximum because you now have to
look at our schools and we know we've
got a massive problem so for Essex
County Council to turn around and at the
moment it may be used 4 500 but it'll be
a secret secret five quid bet it's going
to be more like 5 500 before this
actually takes place and I think I agree
with you about the modeling I definitely
don't agree that Burnham on crack should
be on every option that we're
considering because it seems as though
every time like stick it there you've
got a back no we actually haven't got a
bank we've got to stop doctor surgery
that's under question now which is what
councilor Bell actually turned around
and said our facilities are not there
the infrastructure the road the b1010 we
talked about that and thank you for
putting in place about the railway
infrastructure or the modeling for it
yes not yesterday the day before
accident at tinker's hole and then that
night the accident at the bottom of
Kitts Hill and that's just in one day we
have got even highways recognized as a
problem on the b1010 and what we're
doing now is looking to build along that
Crouch Valley Railway line and let's
have some more problems we don't have
enough problems on our roads as it is so
I don't know how I'm going to vote so
it's going to be interesting but I
certainly don't do not support all the
development coming along the crash
Valley Railway line and I'm actually
really disappointed and I think you'll
find that um cancer physics and
councilor passengers
um inboxes will be filled tomorrow when
they read that thing what says all
Thorne is could take us at 750 I think
it says on the report so I think you
need to check your inboxes tomorrow as
well
um so thank you chairman for allowing me
to a little bit of a grand standing in
my Barbie frock but um thank you thank
you very much indeed Mr altar shawland
please you should end up
I just want to say if we carry on with
our present policy in the present local
plan it's Malden and haybridge and
Burnham on Crouch and that's where all
the growth should be going so if
applications come in
around those settlements and they can
mitigate harm you know we should be
looking to support them because that's
in our local plans
the
auction around along the railway line
on paper that does look like a really
sustainable option because we've got the
railway line if we don't model and
evidence and have a look at that option
where we get to examination we would we
will be questioned about that and I have
to say there's quite a high risk that we
will be sent back to do work because it
is a sustainable option it is a
sustainable suitable option and actually
last time
we've got we kind of got away with the
skin of our tick we should we should
have done the work and the thing is if
we don't do the work on that auction
it will always be it will always be
there we will never be able to kind of
get rid of it in a way because it's it
it on paper it looks really it looks
like a sustainable option we've got the
railway line you could take traffic off
the roads onto the railway loan but but
as I said earlier on in in my in my
presentation
we're going to look at the real evidence
on that
ground because
our
I don't can't plant my gut feeling but
the gut feeling is that that Railway
line doesn't have the capacity to take
growth but we need the evidence and
without choosing the option we can't do
the evidence right
very much councilor please
uh thank you chairman
the key thing about this is everywhere
we'll get some development according to
these options yeah including great totem
including Wiccan Bishops yeah so so it's
not it's not necessary about you know
putting it all in the South it's going
yeah the options say that it will go to
all the large villages
uh there isn't the land in the north to
do anything yeah to put anything bigger
it just isn't there you know I know I
would love to say for the people in
Dengue that it is there but it's not
there
um the interesting about from what I
understand the interesting about the
local plans that have been put on hold
or paused and and hopefully officers can
can back me up on this is It's local
plans that are very close to finishing
that are have been put on hold and not
at the halfway point that we are at and
until we move these options forward we
can't make these these decisions we
can't make these decisions about
flooding we can't make these decisions
about
um the the railway line we can't
actually say you know in terms of we
looked at these options and we can't go
to our neighbors and go right we can't
take it you need to and that's the thing
about moving these options forward it
will give us the evidence to say the we
do not have enough land we do not have
the sustainability to take this in the
modern district and chances Braintree
whatever
you've got to support us and help us on
this unless we move this forward we
cannot actually do those things and
that's the key thing and it's not it's
not finished it's the start and that
that to me is this particular stage it's
the start of the of the real work and
that's why we have to move it forward
and Council said for the last time
councilor fluke please if you could be
success
um good to hear the leaders say that
we're at the start of the process but
previously said we were about halfway
through
um Kevin I first of all I didn't get an
answer about the the Helia healer and
the weights planning inspectors are
giving to it in their decisions and
chairman with regards to the Crouch
Railway line
um I spoke to Anglia greater Anglia
Railway today uh someone was there they
weren't all on strike and it's first
thing they said we've invested millions
of pounds in new uh running stock on the
railway line and uh it's nowhere near
capacity since uh the covid German and
uh
and then they threw a grenade and said
oh they're in talks with a developer
about extending a car park on the
platform at one of the stations on it so
chairman we there seems to be a lot of
things going on out there and the other
thing which get councilor stamp will
remember
um was the the two examinations in
public
um we did the work on the railway line
we proved that the railway line had
capacity Mr Coleman I remember went all
the way through that and both inspectors
both Mr Barclay and Mr Vickery in their
examinations in public
both questioned why we weren't
developing along the couch Valley
Railway line and we were very very lucky
on the second attempt that our plan
actually went through chairman so I'd
like the answer particularly about the
Healer because that really is affecting
things now thank you
okay Mr Winslow is actually going to
give the answer on the Healer
thank you chairman
um so the housing and economic land
availability assessment or healer that
you refer to councilor Fluker
um uh the uh yes um uh the you know the
maps Etc and assessments have all been
carried out but what we what we have to
um uh stress here and we will and do
stress to planning inspectors as well
um is that the Healer at the stage that
the Healer has actually been carried out
it is called a policy off assessment uh
so it's looking at whatever information
we have right now or at the time of the
assessment
um uh to determine whether broadly
speaking not in planning terms but
broadly speaking whether a site couldn't
go forward to the next stage of analysis
um and therefore whether it's acceptable
for that purpose the front of the Healer
the actual written part of it not just
the maps because I think is a tendency
just to go for the blue and red maps and
think that that is the product of the
Healer but the written part of the
Healer does stress uh that um it is uh
for it has been prepared
um on the basis of informing plan making
um and the
um uh you know so certain cautions
should be had interpreting that in a way
for planning applications
um I know that it was mentioned about
healer in terms yesterday's North uh
North East planning committee
um Northwest sorry
um concerning
um the uh concerning the the sort of
weight that officers give the Healer
um and the uh and from an officer
perspective the weight to be given to a
Healer at this stage
until further assessment is done is is
little or no weight
thank you very much
no thank you very much indeed councilor
Darren yeah thank you this this has the
danger of being able to go on all night
and I don't think it should do
chairman I totally agree with councilor
Thompson none of us want anything
anywhere but we know we're gonna have to
take it Northwest area planning last
night
we refused a plan for 50 houses new
houses where now we're heard that that
could be
um part of the the new plan that
generated over 200 letters from
residents there is a plan for tolsbury
another one of those areas identified
which I think has broken the record for
the number of
um letters of objection from residents
so wherever it's going to go and I
accept the fact that we are going to
need new housing but we're going to have
to be able to justify it to our
residents and I totally understand
everybody's problem about option one
option 10 option 99 but we have to do
the work to assess them it's really easy
to take a helicopter view of the
district and anybody doing that would
say oh look there's a railway line look
it's As Nice there's it's not that built
up that's perfect but until you know
more about that area you know it's
low-lying you know the flood problems
you know all the other bits and pieces
and the fact that the Dengue a lot of it
is salt marsh
until you understand those constraints
it's very easy to see from Google Earth
that oh yeah we can put a new new town
here or we can put a no thousand houses
there in order to stop doing that we
have to do this work and I know I
previously said that we should stop the
whole thing but if we're gonna go ahead
with it we need to get the evidence to
support the right places for any growth
and the wrong places for any growth and
that can only come with the research
thank you thank you very much indeed
Council Darren finally Council the
driver
uh thank you chair
um I and I suspect a lot of us here are
struggling with this debate and we're
struggling because we recognize and
we're all hearing time and time again
from residents that actually we've got
houses without the infrastructure
promises were made and they haven't been
frankly delivered
and so we're being put in a position now
where we're being asked to consider
future development future housing with
the possibility of infrastructure or not
and that is a real concern
now uh we are being presented with some
options here
against which evidence has to be drawn
to decide whether they're workable or
not
now I think some of these are just
frankly unworkable
I question whether actually we're going
to get the infrastructure needed to
support some of these developments but
actually it's too easy sadly to stand
here and say our gut reaction is this
won't work you know it just won't work
we hear it time and time again from
residents we know it we live it we see
it day in day out we know it's not
working and we see the traffic jams we
see the fact we can't access doctor's
surgeries you know we see the fact that
kids are being sent out of District to
access School provision both primary and
secondary we see all of that and
actually and if we stood and others
would have stood on a ticket saying
actually something has got to change we
can't carry on Building without the
infrastructure
so at one sense that is where my gut
reaction sits so that's where I I I sit
and yet
if we're going to challenge what's going
on we have to have evidence we can't
Challenge on a gut we've got to
challenge with hard evidence and
hopefully and I'm hoping that that hard
evidence will show that a lot of this is
just not achievable without millions and
millions of pounds going in in terms of
infrastructure development you know if
Devolution gives us a couple of billion
in a year well maybe there'll be enough
for a sort of provision that's needed I
doubt it so I I think we've got some
recommendations here to go away and for
offices to do some detailed work on I
can't see any other way forward
personally and so uh although you know I
reluctantly will probably go along with
this because I can't see any other
option uh I think I am hoping that
actually we build up the evidence for us
to be able to resist some of this
development if we can't actually deliver
the infrastructure that goes along with
this let alone the infrastructure we
need now to actually support the houses
that have already been developed thank
you thank you members we've had a very
robust debate I make no apology for
having such a robust debate for doing
such important issues it would be
disingenuous to the residents that we
all represent so we need to move now to
the vote we have the recommendations on
the table
um
which I'm gonna I won't suffer you're a
recorded vote unless someone's going to
propose themselves but I would like my
own personal vote recorded which I'm
entitled to do thank you well does
anybody want to record a vote first and
foremost if it doesn't matter it's
quarter to ten or not it serves no it's
a question so are we going to do these
members by a sense to agree the options
that are placed upon us on the order
paper
agreed okay
I would uh like to record if if you're
going to do all five in one hit which I
think I think at the beginning you may
have said you were going to deal with
them individually and I think perhaps
chairman you should consider that again
and do that because there seems to be
some kind of dissent certainly to my
right but I don't speak to the left or
the levels
I can't I can't possibly go with the
third recommendation chairman
okay we'll we'll go for the options
individually in that case so option one
those four great great that's agreed
those against
option one do you mean recommendation
yeah recommendation one sorry Tara sorry
yep sorry it's it's good
yep so let me just go again because it's
getting complicated because it's getting
late so option recommendation number one
those in favor can you please place your
hands up so we can clearly see
okay that's in favor and those against
councilor Fluker and councilor Brown and
councilor Bell please if that could be
recorded in the minutes please
I apologize councilor bound
we're a man of my age would be terrible
I can't even see those name plates okay
recommendation number two is uh those in
favor of recommendation number two
please show hands
okay okay that seems to be carried those
against
would anybody like these their their
their descent and urged in the minutes
yes
councilor fluka and councilor Jennings
councilor bill
hand Council siddle Norman and councilor
stamp please loaded those thank you
recommendation three those in favor
please
okay I need to count this I think
because this could really close it's one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve there's twelve in
favor
fourteen
yeah
sorry members could place your hands up
again you know it's coming so Miss
Holmes will count
no pressure
I've got 14. 14 so that's fourteen four
of those against please
number three
yeah hang on number three
Castle passenger yeah yeah okay that was
again
and councilor fluka wishes his vote
against and cancel the stamp and Cyril
Norman
and Castle available and counts for the
passenger and councilor fitek please all
against on that one so that passes
we go to a recommendation number four
those in favor
please raise your hand cut nice and high
it says 18 4 those against
councilor bound councilor Stanford
Council of fluka council windy
labeling sorry and councilor Bell okay
thank you those to be recorded
yes indeed I've asked for all those to
be recorded and finally option number up
my apologies recommendation number five
not to P option six those in favor of
this option
that's 15 for that option those against
these members
councilor bound Council labent counselor
Hayward sorry yeah counselor Haywood
councilor Neil councilor Stan councilor
fluka councilor siddle Norman councilor
Bell please
seven seven Tara please and I'll have
stayed for each of those obviously okay
members thank you very much indeed for
that very long and informed debate we
move on to agenda item 15 which is the
update on the local development scheme
which is found on pages 83 to 102 the
officer present is again Miss Anne altof
Shoreland please
thank you
local development plan review we have to
have one it's a legal requirement we
have to maintain it and we have to
publish it under the under the planning
act we ours has been out of date for
some time so having voted on the options
now and agreed them the L the new LDS
set in front of you now sets out the
timetable for the work that we'll do in
order to have an adopted plan
um I'm not going to go into any more
detail than that really but also in
there is the timetable for in
infrastructure in Levy the back comes in
or sell and or whichever is in the
regulations so we're hoping to adopt the
plan with a fair wind in in terms of how
the inspector are because once we submit
to the inspector we are in their hands
in terms of timetable so we're hoping to
adopt by summer 20
with the the infrastructure that they
adopted the year after
thank you very much any questions thank
you very much indeed
um there's two recommendations from this
report the little one that the revised
local development scheme
2023-2027 be approved publication on the
council's website and little two that
the assistant director for planning and
implementation be granted delegated
authority in consultation with the
chairperson of strategy and resources
committee to amend the local development
scheme tide table should the timetable
slip to ensure the council complies with
legal requirements on maintaining a
local development scheme I propose to
have a secondary councilor fluka
councilor fluke has seconded
members
did you not get your hand went up so
councilor Pratt would second that
okay councilor fluka
um so
um
overall I don't really have any problems
with this report and I don't really have
any problems with the recommendations
but you know Jim bear in mind we have a
shiny new assistant director of planning
and I personally
look forward to welcoming in this
chamber
um but chairman
I think it's just not a case if there's
slippage in this I don't think it's just
a case to say oh let's tell the chairman
of strategy and resources that there's a
bit of slippage I mean where's that
going to end up you know what is
slippage how long is it going to be but
chairman what I would say is Chairman
that I propose that the assistant
director of planning
accounts for
and reports any slippage to strategy
resources because we need to understand
why there is slippage German and and I
think this is such an important project
German uh and and when you look at the
costs involved in delivering what you've
all agreed
um they're absolutely eye-watering and
I'm sure that any figures that you see
mentioned in these reports you can
multiply by a factor of at least 20
um chairman and I I really do think
um that in the same way as the uh the
director of strategy and resources
reports to this committee on the
progression of transformation
the the director of planning or an
officer should actually report to this
committee regularly perhaps at each
meeting the council so that we can keep
track of this and and also
um that really should include an update
from the statutory 151 officer
accounting for the costs because we hear
an awful lot about costs and I don't see
any specific costs going through
committees other than in this report at
the end a lump sum of 100K to do a
highways
piece of work so that that's what I
would add as a I'd like to amend the
second
recommendation and ask for the report
comes to the council
um I mean I'll I'll give way and say
every other meeting but I really do
think this is so important that it
should come
um I can't read the director of service
deliveries face when I haven't got my
something's nodding but I think that's
only because I can't read his face yeah
thank you thank you very much so that's
a proposal for an amendment so that back
second by Council stamp yeah thank you
okay
any other members wish to speak on this
Castle settle thank you
obviously officers will report things
when they need to and
if if if
we start doing additional reporting
then there is extra cost to the project
so I have a concern about agreeing that
recommendation or that amendment to that
recommendation because of the extra cost
that's involved so I would have thought
that we would have had reporting to SNR
and full Council as a matter of course
to obligate officers to do it on a
specific timetable is not what you do on
a project it's it's reported when it
needs to be thank you Mr Winslow please
uh thank you chair
um it's just to uh just to um emphasize
uh what the purpose of this
recommendation was for
um notwithstanding I uh hear what
councilor fluke has um intent is
um so the legislation requires the local
planning authority to maintain the local
development scheme and by that it
translates into a live update
um practically so we have to have the
ability to account for that on our
website
um and ensure that as as true as
possible
um from a from a project perspective we
are reporting uh what the live position
uh what the live position is
um in terms of reporting on this
um we're already responsible for
reporting to strategy and resources
committee because it strategy resources
committee
um is the committee tasked with
preparing the local development plan
um and we also have to report on a
statutory basis in the authority
monitoring reports on an annual basis
um the local developer the local
development scheme can also be reported
as is now to Performance governance and
audit committee as part of normal
monitoring
thank you Mr Winslow
can I start by thanking Mr wimsley for
being very kind to me when he just spoke
and I'd like to welcome you to the
chamber it has the assistant director of
planning and I'm sorry I got my names
muddled up thank you Joe
thank you very much you know cow
suspensely please
thank you chair just to say and I don't
want to go over the matter in this
chamber because I don't feel that it's
appropriate but there are members in
here who are at the leadership meeting
last week where I did pose questions
that I around this and I've gone with
everything tonight because I felt it's
the right thing to do but I did pose
questions and to Mr Mr Winslow as he
knows and I haven't had any answers and
I would like those answers because I've
gone tonight with with some faith and
voted for this but I haven't got my
answers and I don't think it's going to
be appropriate because of what it is to
discuss it in this chamber but I would
like to have those please thank you
thank you
um and yeah cancer stamp
yes thank you I actually don't see the
problem with what councilor fluke has
suggested I mean I'm just looking at an
update that was sent about from um Nick
averley Chelmsford city council chief
executive officer and you know he's
actually put on here about the number of
councils that have issued the section
114 notice and how many think this in
future there's going to be a lot more
and we all know what they are the
section 114 office notices don't we
members so I think we're actually being
quite cautionary to actually bring the
information to council
um I'm I'm quite happy to maybe give way
as as and when but as long as it's in
people's Forefront that we don't want to
be in a position because full Council
hasn't had it reported to but a
decision's been made of slippage which
can be very important for the delivery
of the ldp which is what um Anne's been
saying all along about our time scale
and what we've got to do properly all
we're actually asking or Council fluke
was asking and I've seconded this is
that we get that information and and I
don't actually really think
um it's a well no it's not a problem
because it's the leaders he says as in
does what he likes but when we're
actually asking for checks and balances
as members
um the leader can have his viewpoint on
that but this is what this council is
here to do and to challenge and to make
sure these reports are coming to council
that we see fit and at the moment we do
see fit because we're all in the
financial Challenge and the difficulties
we're in and I don't have a problem with
it and I hope count suspensely has done
very good tonight I'm surprised to be
very quiet I can't you know I was
actually look yeah to you
um so you know she needs the answers and
I think we need these these uh financial
information coming forward thank you
um members first and foremost we're
about five to ten and because we're so
close to the end of the agenda with
respect I would like to keep the meeting
going just to create the agenda if if
the chamber is in favor of that thank
you very much indeed thank you
um
counselor fitic thank you chairman I
mean it's fine to report back to Council
on matters but if if it ends up becoming
a race to me targets that's not going to
be in any of our best interests because
there was some very complex matters to
to resolve not with you know whether we
need to go to the massive Target we've
got on school to build a school being
one of them so I think and also I think
that the danger is is that there seems
to be quite a lot of information
ending up in the hands of developers on
on things that are going on from reports
that they're reading and other stuff so
they will tend to use this information
their advantage if we're too open with
it on the position at any one given time
um so I think the financial side of
different matter altogether I mean it
really doesn't matter to me how quickly
the actual ldp develops I'd probably
prefer it later rather than sooner
um at the end of the day we have a local
development plan that takes us up to
2029 as long as a plan is deemed up
today all the policies within it
um should protect us from adverse
development unless in planning way that
an officer will decide that it's
beneficial rather than half so I don't
think there's really a race on this it
cost is another matter but reporting I'm
not entirely sure okay thank you very
much indeed
um any comment Mr Winslow on that just
more of a statement right members we've
moved the two recommendations are
proposed to take these separately
because we have to take the the first
the recommendations because they've been
seconded so a little one so it's the
reverse the local development scheme
2023-27 to be that's not really
amendment to be approved for publication
on the council's website
so I put that to the to the floor the
members approve or disapprove agreed
agreed as such unanimous agreed
second one if this one fails then we
come through and I'll ask councilor
fluke to raise his his second proposal
there and the decision to record for
planning and implications be granted
delegate Authority in conjunction with
the chairperson strategy and resources
committee to amend the local development
scheme timetable should the timetable
slip to ensure the council complies with
legal requirements on maintaining the
local development scheme is that agreed
anybody second that recorded vote
councilor stem so we have a recorded
vote Tara please
on little two
um
four against or um I want to call your
name please so um starting with cancer
passenger piece
four
okay you count the bell for
eign
four
Council driver
thank you Council
for
eign
against
cancer Hughes
four
Council Jennings
Council wagon I'm staying please Tara
Council Lake
four
[Music]
capsule label
before sorry
Council Morgan four
thank you councilor Morley
against
four
that's a Shaughnessy
that's the sigil four
Council Norman
cancerous Nick's fancy for
four
cancer stamp against
Council Stevens four
Council stilts it's not here sorry
council's Swindle four
Council Thompson four
Council Within
she's not here Tara
was that for five
let's carry ing news thank you very much
indeed we move on to agenda item 16
which is the Essex wide Devolution
update which is a verbal report from Mr
Holmes
thanks Sharon following the update
provided to the last Council and the
slide circulated to all members workers
being ongoing through the summer but
there is little to update members at
this time however discussions between
Essex thurrock and south end and central
government will be happening soon and
the aim is to identify potential options
to explore and agree upon
the first evolution member working group
was held in July and members agreed to
invite councilor Graham Butlins Essex
County Council portfolio Holier and for
divulation to the next meeting of the
group and this will be held in late
September subsequently is the County
Council has also announced the next
round of briefings to all councils
across the county the dates are those
briefings the first of which was held
earlier this evening were circulated to
all members that have to sign up to
attend the second briefing will be held
on Friday the 22nd of September at 10 to
11 in the morning
given the breathings are taking place
it's not intended to duplicate those
briefings now however a high level
summary from the presentation is we are
closer to the start the end of the
journey a number of key stages will need
to be worked through including political
agreement consultation and legal due
process but the desire of Greater Essex
just to complete the process by Autumn
2025. I will ensure the Essie County
council's comprehensive presentation
will be shared with members for in this
meeting and I expect greater progress
will occur before the next V2 Council
and a fuller update will be given at
that time thank you chairman thank you
very much indeed Mr Holmes members
gender item 17 which is oh my apologies
councilor fluke or stamp who's hand
winner first thank you chairman I'm
grateful for the update I mean in the
future
I'm sure you wrote that some time ago
but it would circulate it as a member's
update and I'm sure that'll save us all
a lot of time especially as it's 10
o'clock and I know we all want we all
want to go and I just wondered Mr Holmes
I know it's only just been announced but
the conservative leader of Southend has
actually said that if he doesn't get any
more central government funding he's
going to have to enter into a section
114 agreement which basically means
they're unable to pay for their bills
and they're going to have to cut their
services is that going to affect the
Devolution process because one you know
it's a bit like bringing a group of
companies together and the way things
are in Essex at the moment there's at
least two of them are skint
um and and it seems to me that we could
all pick up the bill and bear in mind
we've got substantial assets to compare
to a lot of our neighbors where does
that actually leave us
sometimes
um this evolution is a greater Essex and
obviously the two unit trees are part of
Essex but Essex is a very large County
with a number of authorities like arose
in so obviously that will have a
potential impact but I would say you
know that is part of all the discussion
that's going to be happening it's for
greater Essex not just one part of thank
you councilor stamp mine's already a
quick one I was surprised to hear today
at that presentation that um we're going
for level two and three I thought we was
going for level three not we as in
cancer Bentley or that the bid was going
to go for level three which was the
mayoral because I think members know
councilor Durham might be able to help
me out if I get a bit mixed up here is
that's where the money is if you're
going for level two don't bother that's
my understanding is that not right
councilor Durham I'm going to put you in
a position
don't worry don't mention it don't say
anything but level three is where you
get the money and you need to hopefully
you can attend these briefings is in
September the 20 whatever it is because
all you need to look at this thing
because it is getting serious now
because I was shocked when they said
that South End and thurrock were the
ones who wanted to go for level two
thank you very much indeed Council
uh yeah it is level three where you get
the extra two billion uh uh pounds so uh
one of the things I would uh I I will
circulate it to uh members one of the
things I would suggest which is the
district council network is pushing for
this is at the moment the bill is going
through Parliament and it's gone back to
the House of Lords and House of Lords
put an amendment that uh every District
Council if there is Devolution will get
a place at the table
uh
no no no that's that's what the
amendment is so the amendment is that
every District Council will get a place
at the table because what's on the table
is that across the eight districts there
will be three Representatives
so it would be up to yeah leaders voting
for that so if you it's it's lobbying uh
MPS
yeah and I have Lobby there our MPS
already about this to vote uh the
district councils get a representation
when the amendment comes back to the
House of Commons so I will circulate
that email to to members thank you very
much just upon your Clarity is it level
three or is it two and and I've
mentioned I saw a giveaway to cat stuff
in a moment but I've noticed I've
mentioned before that uh Bristol
actually voted to get rid of their met
but they're still getting shed loads of
funding there's times
German yet level two um there are
different speed level two and three
level three has the mayor and calcium
stamp is quite correct there are more
powers and more funding assigned to
level three with with a mayor than level
two but Essex are running two scenarios
at the moment a two and a three that's
lovely thank you Mr Holmes okay members
I think we've had the update and um
councilor Durham just finally well
chairman on the basis at councilor stamp
mentioned it uh um it wouldn't be proper
for me to comment because I would be
betraying
um cabinet
um being a member of the cabinet I I'm
Bound by the
um
the confidence the confidentiality
that's the word I was desperately
looking for it is after 10 o'clock yes
I'm obviously Bound by the
confidentiality that that brings so
thank you that's the problem with the
cabinet system so members let's move to
17 questions to the leader of the
council and according to procedure rule
one three M there are none members
you'll be very pleased to know that we
moved to number 18 which is any other
items of business that the chairperson
decides are Urgent I don't have any
thank you counselor and night
it's not railroading over anything we we
have a debate
don't have to ask you can nominate it
within the Constitution you either
nominator you can raise a question to
the leader unannounced you can do that
but you have to notify me
do you have an item a question for the
leader councilor fluka
you've made your point counselor Luca
thank you very much I've any other
business I think with something that we
need to debate another time I don't have
any I was there for members at your will
at your will we close the meeting at 10
10 pm thank you
and that is anti